bonjour à tous vous allez pouvoir suivre
ce matin une audition sur la réforme des
rythmes scolaires ces auditions ont lieu
dans le cadre de la mission commune
d'information sur cette réforme une
mission demander ici par le groupe ump
du sénat alors cette réforme polémique
est désormais mise en place c'est à dire
que 6 millions d'écoliers vont désormais
à l'école quatre jours et demi par
semaine contre quatre jours auparavant
dans la plupart des communes sur le
papier l'objectif est louable alléger
les journées des élèves en répartissant
mieux les 24 heures hebdomadaires et une
fille née lutter contre l'échec scolaire
je vous propose donc d'écouter les
auditions des parents d'élèves devant
des sénateurs
bien je vous souhaite la bienvenue au
sénat je remercie infiniment d'être avec
nous cet après midi dans le cadre des
auditions que nos auquel nous procédons
dans le cadre de la mission commune
d'information sur la réforme des rythmes
scolaires
donc cette seconde édition va nous
permettre d'écouter le point de vue des
parents d'élèves je remercie chacun
d'entre vous d'avoir bien voulu répondre
à notre invitation
l'audition simultanée de toutes les
organisations doivent favoriser notre
réflexion sur la mise en oeuvre de la
réforme je vais donner la parole
successivement à chaque organisation
tout à l'heure pour qu'elle nous
présente son point de vue sur la réforme
et le cas échéant s'éprend de ces
propositions quant à la mise en oeuvre
je demande je vous demanderai à chacun
s'il vous plaît de ne pas excéder dix
minutes de présentation de manière à
laisser place aux questions d'abord de
madame le rapporteur et ensuite de
l'ensemble des sénateurs ici présents et
nous nous nous contraindront dans un
temps de débat global de 2 heures voilà
donc nous avons aujourd'hui avec nous
madame nathalie kojak vice président de
la fédération des conseils des parents
d'élèves la fcpe
accompagné de madame karine autissier
j'ai une mission
madame sophie fontaine présidente de
l'union nationale des associations
autonomes de parents d'élèves l'unap et
monsieur nicolas hardy membres du
conseil d'administration et chargé de
mission sur les rythmes scolaires
nous avons également madame valérie
marty présidente de la fédération des
parents d'élèves de l'enseignement
public appep avec accompagné de madame
myriam menez secrétaire général enfin
monsieur christophe abraham de
l'association des parents d'élèves de
l'enseignement libre l'appel donc je
code je commencerai à j'ai oublié qui s
est madame caroline saliuk est notre
présidente merci bonjour madame la
présidente pardonnez moi
et bien à la il y à un manquement grave
à monsieur robert
voilà c'est peut-être pas les tuyaux
sont peut-être pas aller jusque ans
n'est pourtant pas très loin manque de
communication joue prime excuses et
madame la présidente
bien donc nous allons commencer avec les
présidents présentation en fonction de
l'ordre tel qu'il a été établi dans
notre dans la chronologie de nos
auditions avec madame nathalie gaujac
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs madame la présidente
madame la rapporteure mesdames messieurs
bonjour tout d'abord merci d'auditionner
la fcpe je vous transmets les
salutations et les voeux pour cette
nouvelle année de la part de notre
président paul raout retenu par ses
obligations professionnelles
avant tout je tiens à rappeler que nous
que pour nous parents d'élèves fcpe
ce sont en premier les élèves qui sont
concernés par la réforme est il
important de souligner que pour une fois
dans l'histoire des rimes voire
peut-être de l'école les besoins
prioritaires et spécifiques des enfants
et des jeunes sont prises en compte car
l'objectif premier de la réforme et bien
que les écoliers français ne subissent
plus cette extrême concentration du
temps d'enseignement
concentration du temps qui est inadapté
à leur rythme et préjudiciable aux
apprentissages sur la longueur des
journées de classe le sujet vous le
savez n'est pas nouveau puisque déjà en
1962 le rapport debré doit d'y dénoncer
la fatigue des écoliers français
la fcpe a toujours fondé sa position sur
les travaux des spécialistes
depuis les années 80 les travaux des
chronobiologistes démontre que les
rythmes de l'enfant et ceux de l'école
française ne coïncident pas ne sont pas
en harmonie
l'académie de médecine ne dit pas autre
chose cette réforme est donc en quelque
sorte une prescription médicale dans
l'intérêt des enfants à cette rentrée
près de 25 % des élèves du primaire ont
bénéficié du retour à la semaine de
quatre jours et demi un retour qui
devrait être saluée tant l'organisation
depuis 2008 et l exception française
décrié par tous les acteurs de la
communauté éducative les experts les
hommes et femmes politiques de droite
comme de gauche près d'un écolier sur
quatre a aujourd'hui des journées de
classe plus courte un temps scolaire
mieux réparties dans la semaine
l'objectif principal est donc atteint
faire mieux coïncider les temps de
l'enfant et ceux de l'école nous
constatons d'ailleurs souvent qu'à
rebours des discours des adultes les
enfants sont plutôt contents de faire
des choses différentes dans l'école
content que leurs journées de classes
d'apprentissage scolaire soit plus
courte certains ont dénoncé la fatigue
des enfants en cette rentrée je dirais
quoi de plus normal après huit semaines
de vacances ils ont tous les ans du mal
à reprendre le rythme de l'école à se
lever plus tôt à encaisser aussi la
fatigue intellectuelle
s'ajoute à cela nourrit par le discours
ambiant l'anxiété des parents qui ne
l'oublions pas attendre beaucoup de
l'école à la fcpe nous pensons depuis
longtemps qu'il ne faut pas plus de cinq
heures d'enseignement par jour à l'école
primaire car au delà les enfants ne
peuvent plus correctement assimilé ce
qu'ils apprennent en classe dans le
second degré il faut se limiter à six
heures par jour au collège sept heures
au lycée et 35 eur ttc tout travail
compris avec des emplois du temps pensé
pour les élèves et non pas en fonction
de la disponibilité des adultes
j'ajoute qu'il faudra laisser du temps à
cette nouvelle organisation pour en
mesurer les résultats nous continuons
aussi de penser que la meilleure
organisation de la journée repose sur
une pause méridienne allongé 1h30
minimum quel que soit l'âge de l'enfant
du jeune même si cela pourrait imposer
des contraintes à l'ensemble de la
commune tu es éducative à l'afp nous
sommes donc certain que la semaine de
quatre jours n'est pas adapté au rythme
des enfants et notamment à ceux qui sont
en difficulté au moment de la
concertation nationale sur la
refondation de l'école experts et
enseignants ne disait pas autre chose et
la conférence nationale des rythmes en
2011 préconiser l'abandon de la semaine
de quatre jours et s'interrogeaient même
sur son interdiction cette réforme est
donc une formidable aventure éducative
et pédagogique
elle est une excellente occasion pour
qu'enfin le temps périscolaire soit
reconnu comme un véritable temps
éducatif sans verser nécessairement dans
la surenchère d'activité les enfants ont
aussi besoin d'être au calme de temps
entre copains et parfois même de
s'ennuyer comme le disent les
chronobiologistes des activités
complexes qui demande beaucoup de
concentration sont aussi fatigante que
les activités qui font à l'école inutile
donc de se lancer dans une compétition
pour savoir qui développera l'activité
la plus prestigieuse où la plus coûteuse
d'autant que ces activités doivent
rester gratuite pour les familles n'y at
il pas d'ailleurs une contradiction
entre regretté que les enfants ne
puissent plus se reposer et dormir le
mercredi matin pour ceux qui le peuvent
et exiger toujours plus d'activités nous
avons un moyen de moderniser l'école de
l'ouvrir sur la société de lui donner de
la cohérence à travers les projets
éducatifs de territoire
la transformation de la en profondeur de
notre école est un enjeu crucial pour
l'avenir de nos enfants c'est en
permettant la rencontre des hanches des
intelligences et en construisant
collectivités collectivement que nous
réussirons cette réforme pour les
enfants d'abord cette réforme est donc
une bonne réforme à condition d'être
pensés dans cet intérêt dans l'intérêt
de l'enfant et de mettre de côté nos
intérêts particuliers d'adultes nous
avons en effet remarqué que cela marche
mieux lorsque les choses sont organisées
pour que cela marche mieux et que la
communauté éducative et par là j'entends
parents enseignants élus et éducateurs
dans son ensemble et associés à son
élaboration et à sa mise en oeuvre
locale concernant la mise en oeuvre je
tenais à préciser que notre réflexion
est nourri par les parents d'élèves pour
les élèves on lie ces deux souhaite vous
adresser des prêts colonisation qui
semble important de prendre en compte
créer des lieux de dialogue et de
construction collective pour que les
décisions soient prises avec l'ensemble
des acteurs de la communauté éducative
ces lieux de décisions permettront
également de trouver des réponses
locales pour des questions pratiques
comme les locaux le transport ce qui
permettrait également de soutenir
certains territoires en difficulté dans
la réflexion voire dans la mise en
oeuvre
développer l'aspect pédagogique de la
réforme en diffusant auprès des
enseignants et de tous les éducateurs
les travaux de recherche sur la
chronobiologie et sur l'alternance
équilibré des activités pédagogiques
intégrer la question des devoirs à la
maison qui rappelons sont théoriquement
interdite depuis 1956
rappeler que dans la fatigue des enfants
l'irrégularité des horaires de lever et
de coucher a une part de responsabilité
organiser les horaires en fonction des
besoins physiologiques des élèves ainsi
rappelé que les enfants de maternelle
doivent déjeuner le plus tôt possible et
doivent être couchés également le plus
tôt possible
intégrer le temps de repos quel que soit
l'âge des enfants de manière souple en
tenant réellement compte des besoins et
de la de l'état de fatigue momentanée
sait s'adapter à l'enfant garantir la
gratuité des activités périscolaires
pour les familles la fcpe revendique que
l'argent public aille à la seule école
publique ne pas tomber dans l'appuie
dans le piège de la suractivité
permettre d'étendre détendent et de
décompression de liberté de jeu de rêve
libérer l'enfant de la pression
permanente souvent imposée de façon
inconsciente par les adultes préparer
l'école à accueillir le monde
périscolaire en incitant par exemple à
la rédaction de chartes de partage de
locaux aussi bien pour les salles de
classe que de motricité mais aussi pour
amener la réflexion sur les temps de
transition entre temps scolaire est
temps périscolaire dans les écoles c'est
aussi une occasion d'ouvrir l'école sur
son territoire ouvrir les discussions
sur l'organisation de l'année scolaire
et sur les emplois du temps dans le
second degré pour conclure ce retour à
la une semaine de quatre jours et demi
plus équilibrée danse art et demie cité
et pour la fcpe une des étapes de la
refondation de l'école de la république
l'école publique gratuite et laïque qui
devra permettre à nos enfants à tous les
enfants tout point du territoire
dans une école bienveillante de devenir
les citoyens de demain je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame kojak à présent
madame sophie fontaine présidente de
l'anaf
même la présidente madame la rapporteure
mesdames et messieurs les membres de la
commission
au nom des parents d'élèves autonome et
des associations de parents d'élève
affilié à lui n'a aps je vous remercie
de nous mettre de nous permettre de nous
exprimer sur la mise en place de la
nouvelle organisation du temps scolaire
le ministre a demandé que l'on ne perde
pas de vue le bien-être des enfants
en cela la nouvelle organisation du
temps de travail de remédiation et de
détente constitue une première étape
indéniable
l'unap approuve le principe de
l'allègement de la journée
d'enseignement à 5h30 avec une durée
minimale de la pause méridienne fixé à
1h30 qui nous semble plus respectueuse
des rythmes naturels de l'enfant
en application des principes du
mouvement autonome de parents d'élèves
l'unaf rappelle que toute concertation
avec l'ensemble des partenaires de
l'éducation nationale doit se faire dans
le respect de chacun et doit tenir
compte du choix des parents
en maternelle l'application de la
réforme reste un chantier ouvert mais la
prise en compte de la sieste comme une
activité pleine et entière semble une
bonne chose pour le respect de la
chronobiologie de l'enfant
lui n'a pas demandé à ces associations
locales de participer de manière
positive et constructive à l'élaboration
de leur projet local
les rythmes scolaires que depuis 1976
faisait régulièrement polémique sont
maintenant concrets pour une partie non
négligeable d'établissements scolaires
et de communes
pour autant cette réforme est vécue
comme une véritable révolution de la vie
des écoles des communes mais aussi des
familles
au cours du premier trimestre de l'année
scolaire 2013-2014
les pièces du puzzle se sont mises en
place dans les communes qui
expérimentent de nouveaux rythmes depuis
la rentrée sans doute est il trop tôt
pour tirer des conclusions
objectif des remontées pour la grande
majorité des communes cette année
scolaire 2013-2014 est une année
studieuse
dans les deux cas nous sommes au début
du processus et de nombreux points
d'amélioration demeurent
les problèmes pédagogie pédagogique
cohabitent avec les problèmes techniques
que seul le temps et l'implication de
chacun des partenaires seront en mesure
d'améliorer
nous constatons que dans même dans les
écoles où cela se passe bien
les familles vivent plutôt ce changement
comme une des régularisations non pas du
temps scolaire de l'enfant mais de sa
journée dans sa totalité
nous observons que l'anxiété des parents
ne faiblit pas et les interrogations se
confirme sur les horaires une régularité
de ceux ci est demandée la collation
indispensable à l'allongement de la
durée de la matinée une aide plutôt
logistique de la commune la
qualification des personnels recrutés
la diversité l'hétérogénéité des
activités proposées la gratuité des
activités pour les enfants qui
participent
la liberté de choix laissé aux enfants
et aux parents d'y participer de les
pratiquer la confusion entre le temps
scolaire et le temps périscolaire pour
les enfants
le choix de la demi journée
concernant la demi journée de travail
supplémentaire lui n'a pas laissé le
choix aux associations locales
d'élaborer le meilleur dispositif
dans leur grande majorité les parents
d'élèves autonome regrette que le
mercredi et était imposé de manière
administrative
l'unaf rappelle que le samedi matin est
une matinée favorable aux échanges entre
les deux parents et l'équipe enseignante
nous demandons une équité de traitement
pour les projets dits dérogatoire
par ailleurs les craintes demeurent en
ce qui concerne l'organisation d'étape
nous souhaiterions une visibilité
d'ensemble sur les offres d'activités
pédagogiques
complémentaires proposés et les
activités périscolaires
ces activités doivent être mises en
cohérence et s'articuler entre elles
le financement notre union nationale a
conscience qu'il faudra du temps et un
financement adéquat pour mener à bien
l'application du décret nous regrettons
que les collectivités locales soient de
nouveau mis à contribution sans
bénéficier dans la durée d'une
compensation financière satisfaisante ni
d'ailleurs d'un mécanisme de péréquation
permettant aux petites communes d'offrir
des prestations similaires aux grandes
communes
nous rappelons que la gratuité de
l'enseignement est un principe majeur de
la république et qu'à ce titre la mise
en place d'activités onéreuse dans le
cadre de l'école nous sommes au
contraire au principe d'équité entre nos
enfants au sein d'une même école
par ailleurs nous interrogeons sur les
nouvelles attributions mater
d'enseignement donner aux municipalités
car pour la première fois ces
collectivités n'ont pas seulement une
obligation de mise en oeuvre de moyens
mais également de réalisation d'un
projet éducatif
nous constatons que l'équité
d'enseignement et d'activités entre tous
les enfants est mise à mal
la qualification des personnels recrutés
nous pensons que les équipes
d'animateurs devant être renforcée et
stabiliser en nombre d'effectifs
afin de mettre fin au statut précaire
d'une catégorie d'animateur qui
fragilise l'action des accueils de
loisirs entraînant une rotation
incessante de ses personnels
d'encadrement
l'unaf demande que de vraies
perspectives professionnelles leur soit
offerte
afin de se donner les moyens et les
ambitions qualitatif pour nos enfants
l'unap souhaite pour les communes
n'ayant pu recruter les personnels
compétents pour la mise en place de
cette réforme une disposition
transitoire leur permettent de
bénéficier d'une année supplémentaire
l'unap souhaite également le décret
que ce que le décret sur la réforme des
rythmes scolaires
bénéficient d'une nouvelle lecture par
les parlementaires et ce pour mettre fin
à la mise en place d'une inégalité de
traitement et d'accès au savoir pour se
donner les moyens de rendre l'étape
obligatoire et de ce fait gratuit
en conclusion nonobstant un réel manque
de concertation une trop faible prise en
compte de la vie des familles nous
constatons à travers tous les
témoignages reçus un vrai besoin de
réformes une réelle volonté de
participer à sa mise en place d'être
acteur actif plutôt que passif
de nombreuses associations ont réalisé
un véritable travail de partenariat au
service des enfants des parents mais
aussi des enseignants afin que cette
réforme qui sera adopté in fine et par
tous à la rentrée prochaine
répondent aux besoins et favorise un
épanouissement pour tous
depuis la mise en place des rythmes
scolaires dans certaines écoles les
parents ont demandé à rectifier certains
paramètres tels que les horaires de
cantine
l'organisation des activités la
redistribution des locaux
dans trop de cas encore l'intérêt de
l'enfant passe après celui de l'adulte
très peu d'associations extérieurs sont
parties prenantes pour le moment dans
les activités périscolaires on sent un
flottement quant aux partenariats
extérieurs à mettre en place le choix se
portant le plus souvent sur des
animateurs diplômés sans doute joue-t-on
la carte de l'habitude ou de la sécurité
certaines villes essaie d'y répondre en
mutualisant leurs moyens et réduisant de
cette manière les coûts pour la commune
donc pour les familles et les autres
contribuables dans beaucoup de localités
on dénonce l'obligation de devoir
supporter un coût sans l'avoir choisi
en application des principes du
mouvement autonome de parents d'élèves
l'unap respecte les décisions des
associations locales nous souhaitons que
les réflexions les autres relations qui
seront évoqués lors des prochains
conseils d'école le soit dans le respect
des parents et du lunain n'oublie pas ce
qui est proposé à vocation à sortir de
la situation actuelle c'est à dire
améliorer notre système éducatif
remonter dans le classement pisa former
nos enfants aux enjeux du futur
pour cela passera par une pleine
collaboration avec les enseignants et
l'acquisition de nouvelles techniques de
travail d'équipé entre eux le mouvement
autonome de parents d'élèves attend
beaucoup de la refonte des programmes
sans laquelle la réforme des rythmes
scolaires n'aura pas de véritable sens
il nous reste toutefois à inventer une
école qui permettent à chacun de nos
enfants de ne plus se sentir rejeté du
fait d'une sélection trop hâtives une
école qui donne du temps aux enfants
dans l'acquisition de leurs compétences
en particulier par l'instauration d'
unité de valeur au sein de leur cursus
aussi et enfin au delà de l'acquisition
du socle des connaissances une école qui
valorise la compétence de chacun de nos
enfants tout au long de ces
apprentissages merci merci madame
fontaine la parole et madame haman à
marty président de l'apec
merci de nous accueillir et de nous
permettre de parler des rythmes
scolaires un sujet qui est très
intéressant est important pour les
poulets parents d'élèves pour la pep le
sujet de l'aménagement du temps scolaire
est un vieux sujet on ça remonte dans
les années 50 même si on peut vraiment
réfléchir un peu et regarder ce qu'on a
fait depuis et les réflexions que nous
avons mené je pense qu'on ne peut pas
pour nous on regrette un petit peu que
les rythmes scolaires l'aménagement du
temps scolaire était était uniquement
abordé sur la semaine et la journée il y
a aussi le débat sur la répartition des
vacances scolaires et c'est important il
faudrait que on s'attache à cela
dans un premier temps nous avons
regretté l'absence d'une concertation
nationale sur la mise en oeuvre de la
réforme parce que si on a parlé d'un
consensus au niveau je dirais de l'idée
d'un aménagement d'une réflexion puisque
ça fait de fort longtemps qu'on
travaille que nous travaillons tous
ensemble dessus
sur la mise en oeuvre qui est
le vraiment le dire le coeur du sujet
aujourd'hui nous aurions aimé travailler
réellement et ça pour nous aurait
nécessité probablement une grande
réunion nationale avec tous les acteurs
collectivités locales enseignants
parents d'élèves associations pour
vraiment travailler finement et voir ce
que l'on pouvait proposer donc c'est un
petit peu avec dommage qu'on a vu
arriver un décret au conseil supérieur
de l'éducation mal ficelé mais je dirais
c'est dommage parce qu'il n'est même pas
passé en commission spécialisée juste un
regret donc c'est pour ça on aurait
peut-être pu travailler un petit peu en
amont et prendre un peu le temps
de faire cette réforme donc premier
constat sur une précipitation qui
n'était pas forcément nécessaire en tout
cas pour nous une réforme donc très
complexe à mettre en oeuvre parce que
lorsqu effectivement
la réforme des quatre jours lorsque les
communes sont toutes passées à quatre
jours nous avons perdu avec l'aide
personnalisé deux heures donc ça
complique évidemment le retour aux
quatre jours et demi il ne faut pas
l'oublier
les communes qui ont mis en oeuvre les
la réforme des rythmes scolaires en 2013
ont
consulté les parents d'élèves les
enseignants etc néanmoins ce que nous
nous avons constaté c'est bien dommage
ce qui fait aussi que les parents sont
un petit peu dans le mal est réparé fois
les représentants de parents d'élèves ou
même les élus les enseignants c'est que
les conseils d'école ont été une
instance qui pourtant qu'à tout son sens
dans les rythmes scolaires je dirais on
était un petit peu exclus des
discussions parfois on a voté les
organisations parfois on les a pas voté
on est aussi pour les communes qui sont
en train de discuter sur 2014 qui ont
fixé les horaires parfois ils ont
demandé au conseil d'école de toutes
leurs écoles de voter parfois c'était
juste pour une présentation une grande
confusion et c'est bien dommage parce
que le conseil d'école est une vraie
instance d'une vraie c'est là où
vraiment la communauté éducative dans
son sens existent réellement donc c'est
un petit peu dommage que ce ce conseil
n'est pas pu participer à cet
aménagement du temps scolaire alors on a
eu des commissions jédir aux contours
très divers c'est à dire que parfois
dans certaines communes on a les parents
d'un côté les enseignants de l'autre où
les parents et les directeurs d'école
qui ne sont pas les supérieurs
hiérarchiques bien évidemment des
enseignants dont des équipes
pédagogiques sont pas forcément
représentés par des jantes pour elle qui
sont représentatives dans des choses
très très compliqué
voit un moment donné sur une
organisation très compliqué ou à la fois
on a le temps scolaire donc de la
responsabilité de lier des liens est né
du désir de l'autre côté des temps
d'activités périscolaires de la
responsabilité du maire avec une
commission on sait pas qui décide de
quoi et comment le lien se fait donc un
grand malaise dans l'organisation je
dirais qui fait qu'effectivement c'est
compliqué et qui gère le global qui va
dire si c'est bien réellement
l'organisation que propose la mairie eh
bien on n'a pas réellement de d'organes
je dirais de validation entre guillemets
puisque on a des organisations parfois
des propositions qui font que les deux n
valide simplement les horaires de sortie
de temps de classe et qu'après ce qui
est proposé c'est proposé par la mairie
c'est de la responsabilité du maire donc
c'est là où la difficulté se fait et
parfois on a des organisations qui
paraisse difficile 20 on comprend
difficilement comme par exemple des
mairies propose une heure de sortie une
heure plus tard c'est à dire qu'on
allonge la journée de classe je dirais
le temps de présence à l'école d'une
heure puisque on a des propositions
maintenant d'organisation où les enfants
sortiront de leurs activités
périscolaires à 17h30 au lieu de 16h30
donc des choses qui sont parfois
surprenants pourquoi pas mais voilà
c'est une question pour nous qui nous
paraissent importantes de savoir qui va
gérer qui j'ai réellement le temps
global puisque maintenant il faut parler
d'un temps global de l'enfant
alors nous demandons bien évidemment la
gratuité ses activités périscolaires
alors elles ne sont pas tous gratuite
hélas dans certaines communes il faut
dire que il y a un accès qui est réservé
aux familles lorsqu'il faut que les deux
familles travaillent les deux parents
travaillent pour avoir cet accès aux
activités périscolaires avec cette pose
quand même problème parce qu'une sortie
à 15 euros à 15h45 c'est quand même et
puis sur le solide et même de la réforme
et de l'équité un petit peu des enfants
voilà donc ça ça arrive donc pour nous
ça nous pose problème dans d'autres
communes vous avez à la fois la garderie
gratuite et en face les belles activités
mais qui elles sont payantes donc en
termes de des qualités et ça c'est des
grandes villes un je parle je peux pas
dire qu'elles sont je ne les nommerai
pas mais ce sont des grandes villes
c'est très choquant réellement c'est
très choquant et ça ne va pas dans le
bon sens donc nous nous sommes pour la
gratuit et attention parce que dans
beaucoup de communes qui sont en train
de discuter en 2014 c'est plutôt
l'aspect payant c'est à dire ce sont les
usagers qui payent donc il faut quand
même s'alerter là dessus on voit bien
les inégalités bien évidemment qui sont
offerts les inégalités territoriales
c'est à dire qu'une commune comme paris
bien évidemment n'a pas les mêmes moyens
qu'une commune qui est de l'autre côté
du périphérique mais bien évidemment on
n'aura pas les belles activités comme
moi j'ai vu effectivement que la ville
de paris peut mettre en place et bon ça
c'est une évidence mais je pense qu'à un
moment donné il faudra mais il faut
quand même posé ça il faut quand même
qu'on réfléchisse ensemble à à cela et
ça nous paraît important quand même
voilà même si en termes d'objectifs de
la réforme il faut quand même dire et
les autres organisations en ont parlé
attention à la surenchère d'activité les
communes veulent bien faire et en
faisant bien et bien on fait mal tu
désolé de le dire mais c'est ça c'est à
dire qu'on veut montrer qu'on a des
belles choses etc mais ce n'est pas le
but de la réforme il faut du temps pour
expliquer à tous que le but de la
réforme c'est de prendre en compte le
rythme psycho
chronobiologique je vais y arriver de
l'enfant c'est à dire qu'à tension un
enfant a besoin de pause un enfant a
besoin de ne rien faire un enfant a
besoin à un moment donné de se poser est
d'avoir des temps calmes ce n'est pas ce
que la réforme nous propose et c'est
bien dommage quand on regarde un petit
peu le rapport et qu'on relit le rapport
de l'académie de médecine il pointait
qu' il y avait des pics de vigilance
d'attention de l'enfant 2 1 le matin de
10h à 11h dont la réforme le respecte
c'est très bien l'après midi de 15
heures à 16 heures donc à quelle heure
sont placés ces activités péri et du
gris scolaire et bien entre 15h et 16h
voilà donc ça ça nous a posé un problème
je comprends bien la contrainte qui est
de trouver un à un par un accord un
consensus entre les parents d'élèves les
animateurs les enseignants mais
réellement il faut quand même un moment
donné poser ces choses
l'organisation doit tenir compte aussi
de l'âge de l'enfant parce qu'un enfant
qui est petit n'a pas les mêmes besoins
qu'un enfant qui plus grand donc les
enfants de matin elle nous avons été les
premiers à alerter le ministère là
dessus et et bien non pas les mêmes
besoins que les enfants qui sont en
élémentaire donc je pense qu'il ya des
mairies je dis très honnêtement et des
mairies qui ont eu cette cette vision
une première approche qu'on dit bah
écoute et on va même la mairie de paris
a dit ben non je vais faire une
organisation particulière pour les
maternelles et une organisation pour les
élémentaires et bien ça c'est une bonne
approche sauf qu'après l'éducation
nationale dit mais je n'arriverai pas à
gérer mes enseignants c'est trop
compliqué que ces terrains voilà bon moi
je vous dise qu'on nous a dit mais je
pense qu'il est nécessaire au niveau de
la maternelle de repenser les enfants
n'ont pas les mêmes besoins la peau du
mercredi matin semble d'abord d'après le
rapport de l'académie de médecine
important pour des enfants d'un jeune
âge
les activités péri scolaires qui sont
proposés en maternelle c'est difficile
de les mettre en place c'est difficile
d'offrir des activités à ses enfants
c'est difficile d'avoir des encadrants
formés pour des jeunes enfants c'est
très très compliqué il faut bien
l'avouer et donc il est en tout cas pour
nous à l'heure actuelle nous demandons à
ce que la réforme ne soit pas
obligatoirement n'oblige pas les
communes au niveau des maternelles si
elles se sentent pas capables de le
faire de de faire de passer à quatre
jours et demi pour les écoles
maternelles et peut-être se concentrer
peut-être ou préférablement sur les
écoles élémentaires ou là effectivement
on peut proposer des activités et c'est
plus facile aussi pour les communes
alors nous avons noté nous un certain
nombre de choses sur lesquelles se sont
ce qu'on appelle nous des points
saillants
que on trouve important c'est
l'impréparation de la liaison du temps
d'enseignement du temps périscolaire
c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas pensé à cette
zone cette année qu'on passe du temps
d'école au temps du tap c'est à dire que
les enfants passent d'un temps à l'autre
sans récréation 100% zone tampon et et
voilà donc c'est une accumulation
d'activité l'après midi et il n'y a pas
cette cette possibilité qui est offerte
aux enfants de vraiment un sas de
décompression
on voit bien que ça n'a pas été pensé on
a plutôt bouché les les emplois du temps
on les a rempli d'activités sans penser
à ces temps là et je pense que c'est
important de le faire
la formation des encadrants aussi leur
capacité à gérer une activité évidemment
seuil et c'est pas évident lorsqu'on a
des objectifs entre garder des enfants
animé plus ou moins vers une garderie
garder des enfants et avoir des
objectifs d'activité c'est à dire que
j'ai une idée je leur fais reversât j'ai
un projet et je vais essayer d'amener
les enfants à ça et c'est certainement
un tout petit peu plus de compétences
donc effectivement il faut que les
encadrants sont un peu plus mieux formés
et bon ça pose mais ça vous le savez un
certain nombre de problèmes et surtout
je dis c'est pour les les jeunes enfants
les problèmes de sécurité aussi au sein
des écoles c'est un vrai problème je
sais que des ajustements et effets dans
les écoles qui sont passés en 2013
néanmoins il perdure le nombre
d'intervenants le nombre de personnes
qui sont dans l'école qui sont pas
forcément qui change quand on a des
bénévoles donc on les a pas forcément
identifier ces décès c'est des choses
qui existait avant bien évidemment
lorsque on avait après le temps scolaire
les garderies existait et ses problèmes
de sécurité existant déjà bien
évidemment mais là on les met en exergue
puisqu'on a un temps qui est plus grand
gérer et puis surtout sur les bénévoles
qui interviennent dans le temps dans le
temps périscolaire
que comment sont ils recrutés qui sont
ces personnes qui les as sécurité qu'on
a que ces personnes vis-à-vis des des
enfants est ce qu on a contrôlé leur
casier judiciaire choses comme ça sur
les questions que se posent les parents
parce qu'effectivement il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de personnes qui interviennent
auprès des enfants
ensuite quelque chose qui est qui
demandera un peu plus de temps mais
néanmoins qui est nécessaire et
l'absence de cohérence éducative entre
le temps scolaire avec les règles les
règles le règlement intérieur de l'école
comment se comporte avec les enfants et
l'étape c'est à dire est-ce que j'ai les
mêmes règles et ce que j'ai les mêmes
attentions est ce que les règles
d'autorité les règles de vie sont les
mêmes et bien souvent ils ne sont pas
les mêmes voilà parce qu'on n'a pas eu
le temps de réfléchir au niveau du
dialogue
on n'a pas le temps de se poser pour
faire un règlement intérieur
qui est de se poser et de se dire voilà
effectivement la manière dont on se
comporte c'est ce qu'on accepte qu'on
n'accepte pas il faut effectivement qui
est une règle une cohérence entre ces
temps là et c'est nécessaire de le faire
ensuite vient maintenant au fur et à
mesure la problématique de l'inclusion
des enfants porteurs de handicap sur ses
activités avec effectivement la présence
ou non d'un bs ça va être un sujet
prégnant et
c'est important aussi de pouvoir
réfléchir à cela comment on intègre ses
enfants à ses activités le
positionnement de l'apc
ou et il me
les activités pédagogiques
complémentaires une nouvelle aide
personnalisée c'est intéressant d'aller
regarder où on les a placés parce que
parfois ils sont placés les apc le
mercredi matin c'est à dire après les
trois heures où les deux heures et demie
de de cours à la fin comme un petit peu
et c'est important que je pense que
l'apc on fasse une attention
particulière sur le positionnement de
cette aide de se tendre complémentaire
et supplémentaire
pour nous en tout cas ce que nous avons
constaté c'est que le morcellement de
l'emploi du temps les saucissonnage
n'est pas bon pour les enfants c'est ce
qu'ils les désoriente surtout s'ils sont
jeunes il est important de réfléchir la
fluidité fluidification des temps que ça
soit des hauts niveaux de les objectifs
pédagogiques un des objectifs est aussi
des cohérence éducative
alors ce qui nous paraît aussi pour
conclure je dirais je pense qu'il est
important dans leur haut niveau de
l'aménagement du temps scolaire c'est un
sujet dont les parents d'élèves sont
quand même
avec les enseignants les moteurs ce sont
les acteurs ils doivent être à mon avis
lieu consultez le dialogue doit se faire
et le dialogue doit prendre du temps
donc il faut laisser aux communes je
sais qu'elles sont encore en train de
travailler discuter encore avec les
enseignants les parents je pense qu'il
est nécessaire de ce temps soit donné et
qu'on écoute les parents dans leurs
attentes et que l'aménagement se fasse
pas de manière autoritaire dont comme
dans certains cas afin qu'ils puissent
être participer beaucoup plus c'est que
réellement la notion de communauté
éducative et tout son sens dans sur ce
thème
merci beaucoup madame marty la dernière
présentation
c'est madame caroline saliou présidente
de l'apel qui va nous la faire oui merci
madame la présidente madame le
rapporteur mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs ce sera une présentation à
deux voies et puisque je suis là en tant
que présidente et christophe abraham est
là en tant que permanent et il fait
partie nous avons mis en place au sein
de l'enseignement catholique un groupe
de travail sur la mise en place de ces
rythmes scolaires et c'est christophe
abraham qui siègent les rythmes
scolaires
une histoire long d'une histoire à
rebondissements une histoire qui date
depuis 30 40 50 ans on a depuis le début
oublié que c'était l'intérêt de l'enfant
qui était au coeur de ces rythmes
scolaires on a cru au départ de la
réforme de la refondation de l'école que
tout le monde s'intéressait
à l'enfant que l'intérêt de l'enfant
était une des priorités et puis les mois
passant on s'est aperçu que chacun
ramener la couverture à soi parents
compris en se disant eh bien moi je vais
changer mon rythme aussi et ça ne me
convient pas les enseignants de la même
façon donc nous nous voulons et nous
tenons à garder absolument un regard
positif sur cette réforme et sur la mise
en place de rist ses rythmes scolaires
parce qu'on sait depuis des années que
les rythmes ne sont pas bons que les
enfants fatigue que les enfants ne sont
ne vont pas avec plaisir à l'école quand
on sait que 70 % des listes des
collégiens en 4e 10 s'ennuyer à l'école
sans pour autant être en difficulté mais
quand en 4e déjà on ne va pas de bon
coeur au collège ça dénote quelque chose
alors bien évidemment un enfant qui va
bien va bien et s'adaptera à tous fois
mais qu'est ce que l'on fête ses cent
cinquante mille jeunes qui sortent du
système scolaire sans formation c'est
bien parce qu'à un moment donné le
rythme de l'école de leur a pas convenu
faut donc continuer cette réforme
allons-y ayant un regard positif ne
soyons pas dans le dénigrement permanent
et puis arrêtons de concentrer nos
regards sur le périscolaire la réforme
des rythmes scolaires ça n'est pas le
périscolaire c'est la journée chat
comment ça va se dérouler cette journée
comment l'at on réduit qu'est ce qu'on
va pouvoir en faire
comment allons-nous après déroulées la
semaine le mois l'année on a pas reparlé
du mois de juin je vais vous en reparler
dans mon propos un peu plus tard et
voilà on a toute l'année à repenser on a
les programmes à repenser la réforme des
rythmes ne va pas se faire sur trois
mois la les trois premiers mois de
l'année scolaire qui viennent de se
dérouler où tout le monde condamne tous
les sons du temps adaptons nous sachons
corriger ce qui ne va pas dans cette
réforme chacun dans son établissement
concertons nous je pense que la première
des choses c'est que la réflexion doit
avoir lieu au sein de l'établissement en
communauté éducative à les mairies ne
peuvent pas imposer sous des prétextes
mais j'entends les problèmes financiers
des mairies ont on est allé vers eux en
disant c'est vous qui allez oui on en
est bien sûr mais la première des
concertations doit avoir lieu à
l'intérieur de l'école quel projet
mettons nous en place quels rythmes
scolaires par rapport à quel projet
éducatif quel projet d'établissement on
en n'est pas toujours là aujourd'hui
certains l'ont bien réussi cette réforme
je crois que c'est valérie marty qui l'a
évoqué tout à l'heure dans certains
endroits ça se passe très très bien mais
il doit y avoir un long il un lien forme
fort entre le les rythmes scolaires la
réforme des rythmes scolaires et le
projet d'établissement
alors j'en étais où
donc oui on doit garder à l'esprit donc
ce temps de vie des élèves en classe la
vie de la classe c'est vraiment le point
fondamental de la réforme alors quatre
jours quatre demi journées sur cinq
jours ça fait cinq matinées pour les
enfants c'est vraiment là où le temps
d'apprentissage et le plus optimal pour
les enfants donc c'est à ce moment là
qu'il faut savoir quelles compétences on
veut leur faire acquérir quels
enseignements fondamentaux on va mettre
sur ses cinq demi journées
pour nous il semblerait que et pour les
chronobiologistes d'ailleurs que la
coupure du mercredi matin était une fin
du mercredi était une bonne coupure est
que plus tôt en étant sur quatre jours
et demi prenons le samedi matin alors
j'entends aussi les mairies qui
financièrement ou
si on allait vers le collège les
conseils généraux qui ont du mal à voir
côté financier 7
cette demi journée du samedi matin et
pour autant c'est vraiment celle qui
conviendrait le mieux aux enfants et là
c'est vraiment aux enfants parce que les
parents aussi on a besoin de leur
expliquer ne sont pas d'accord sur 20
pour la plupart à un certain je pense
qu'il ya une réelle réflexion tu as une
réelle responsabilité des fédérations de
parents pour aller vers les familles
vers les parents pour leur expliquer ce
qu'est le rythme d'un enfant et ce qui
est une semaine pour un enfant scolarisé
donc lundi mardi travailler le matin
principalement la coupure du mercredi
pour leur permettre de récupérer parce
que même si on nous dit ils vont en
nourrissent ils vont dans une crèche ou
enfin une garderie ça n'est pas la même
chose que d'être en classe et d'être
dans un endroit où on doit acquérir des
compétences où on doit travailler donc
la coupure du mercredi le jeudi vendredi
comme le lundi mardi travailler et le
samedi matin ou là on pourrait permettre
aux enfants et bien de de revoir
certaines acquisitions qui sont un peu
plus faibles
avoir du temps différent avec eux pour
les enseignants ça n'est pas la même
chose non plus et puis ça permet aux
parents puisqu'on sait que ce lien
famille école est extrêmement important
pour la réussite de l'élève
ça permet aux parents le samedi matin de
rejoindre l'école d'avoir ce lien avec
l'établissement scolaire qui est
extrêmement important que l'enfant sorte
que son parent son ouïe son parent et
près de lui à l'école alors c'est vrai
que pour les familles divorcées c'est un
véritable souci on ne peut pas on ne
peut pas il est difficile d'imposer à
certains parents d'être présent le
samedi matin à l'école quand on habite à
150 kilomètres du lieu de scolarisation
de son enfant mais voilà si on reste sur
l'intérêt de l'enfant c'est vraiment le
samedi matin qui est qui est important
il faut absolument garder une vraie
pause méridienne d'une heure et demie
c'est important pour les enfants le midi
de récupérer un peu de souffle et
par le biais du repas et puis d'attendre
décontraction sur sur la cour ou
ailleurs
le périscolaire le périscolaire même si
ça n'est pas comme je les ai dit au
début de mon propos le coeur de la
réforme c'est pas sur ça que doit
apporter toute la réforme il est quand
même très important de mettre des choses
des activités intéressantes pour les
enfants en place il faut donc que ce
périscolaire soit aussi en lien avec le
projet d'établissement avec le projet
éducatif donc ce qui nécessite une
concertation importante entre la
communauté éducative
et puis les associations les groupes qui
pourraient venir dans cette
entrée dans ce lien avec l'école au
travers du périscolaire ce qui permet
aussi de développer chez certains
enfants en fonction de ce qu'on va leur
faire faire sur le périscolaire de
développer certaines autres compétences
ils vont pouvoir se réaliser au milieu
d'une activité s'ils sont en difficulté
à l'école leur faire faire une autre
activité je ne sais pas moi du théâtre
du cinéma où ils vont exceller ça va
leur redonner confiance en eux et ça va
avoir un bénéfice sur le temps scolaire
et l'acquisition des compétences
scolaires purement donc ne négligeons
pas ce périscolaire et mettant le bien
en lien avec le projet d'établissement
ça permet aussi à certaines familles de
d'accéder à certaines activités qu'il ne
pourrait pas faire
sur un temps familial ou personnel parce
que la famille n'a pas
la possibilité financière ou n'a pas
alors c'est difficile de dire ça mais
socialement
n'a pas cet état d'esprit de faire
participer leurs enfants à certaines
activités donc pour certaines familles
c'est vraiment
c'est indispensable
il faut aussi évidemment on l'a évoqué
au départ qu' un lien entre le projet
d'établissement et le périscolaire mais
il faut aussi qu'ils aient un lien fort
entre les enseignants le travail des
enseignants et le périscolaire
alors évidemment évidemment mais mes
collègues l'ont évoqué tout à l'heure ça
n'est absolument pas une garderie qui
doit être proposé
aux établissements et c'est ce que l'on
entend le plus souvent en ce moment
c'est que la réforme est décriée le
périscolaire est décrié parce que
beaucoup pour mettre en place cette
réforme sont allés vers de la garderie
et j'oserais même allé jusqu'à dire
jusqu'à des gardiennage ce qui fait que
les enfants on apporte rien aux enfants
intellectuellement physiquement ça ne
leur donne rien du tout et bien au
contraire ils sont beaucoup plus fatigué
que par le passé sur la semaine de
quatre jours donc on a toujours dit que
la semaine de quatre jours n'était pas
bonne et est là en ce moment est bien
certain reviendrait bien à la semaine de
quatre jours parce que ce qu'on a mis en
place est encore plus fatigants pour les
enfants-
je voudrais revenir aussi dans le cadre
du périscolaire sur quelque chose que
l'on a beaucoup évoqué au début de la
refondation ou au début de la réforme
c'est les devoirs à l'école et là nous
nous sommes extrêmement déçus parce que
on n'en parle plus et nous estimons que
les devoirs s'il était fait à l'école
permettrait aux enfants qui sont dans
des familles où les parents travaillent
beaucoup rentrent tard ou dans des
familles où on n'est pas en capacité de
faire faire les devoirs ça crée une
inégalité entre les enfants qui sont
scolarisés donc rien n'empêche les
familles de s'intéresser au travail
scolaire et de jeter un oeil dans le
cartable et les cahiers des enfants le
soir quand il rentre mais il faudrait
absolument que ses devoirs soient faits
à l'école dans le cadre de l'égalité des
chances des enfants en milieu scolaire
alors je pense que sur les difficultés
que nous avons rencontrées pour la mise
en oeuvre de ces rythmes scolaires c'est
en partie parce que on a voulu imposer
on va dire de paris mais je me sens les
fédérations sont au siège à paris mais
les établissements les communautés
éducatives
on pensait que les les directives venait
de paris qui s'était imposé je pense
enfin nous pensons qu'il faut laisser
une autonomie une liberté aux
établissements aux communautés
éducatives et que les rythmes scolaires
qu'on voulait on va pouvoir mettre en
place dans un établissement en fonction
du projet d'établissement du projet
éducatif le rythme n'est pas forcément
le même dans l'école d'à côté je suis
allé deux fois trois fois l'année
dernière dans les dom par exemple ce que
l'on propose ici en métropole n'est pas
adaptable dans les dom parce que les
enfants se lèvent extrêmement tôt le
matin pour des questions de déplacement
voilà c'est comme ça la chaleur fait
aussi que voilà donc ça n'est pas
adaptable les enfants qui sont en
montagne je pense que ce que l'on peut
imposer alors on peut donner un cadre
mais la mise en oeuvre je vous sens
concerné
on donne un cadre mais il faut laisser
une certaine autonomie dans la mise en
oeuvre de ces rythmes scolaires il faut
évidemment j'aurais évoqué au début de
mon propos
on a on a pensé la journée la semaine
mais on n'a pas repenser l'année et on
reste toujours sur ses transes 36
semaines travaillées il faudrait
vraiment laissé plus de souplesse au
déroulement de l'année pourquoi pas
réduire les vacances scolaires qu'est ce
que l'on fait ce mois de juin qui est
quasiment laissé
où on laisse déjà les enfants à la
maison alors que là on pourrait en
profiter pour mettre des choses en place
aussi
il faut adapter ces rythmes scolaires et
là on l'a vu je crois que l'expérience
est assez significatif depuis la rentrée
scolaire entre la maternelle primaire et
puis je crois qu'on s'oriente vers le
collège et lycée par la suite il faut
vraiment adapté les rythmes en fonction
de l'âge de l'enfant est ce qu'on a fait
pour le premier degré il aurait fallu
qu'ils aient une différenciation entre
maternelle et primaire
donc dans les regrets que nous avons
c'est que souvent le projet
d'établissement est oublié dans la
réforme des rythmes parce que je
persiste à dire que sans doute dans
certains endroits et pas partout parce
qu'il ya de belles réussites et ça on
n'en parle pas suffisamment hinse on ne
s'en sert pas et en france on a ce
défaut de ne pas savoir prendre ce qui
marche bien dans certains cas on est
dans le cadre scolaire donc dans les
établissements scolaires pour s'en
servir ailleurs tout n'est pas adaptable
partout mais quand quelque chose marche
bien sachons le faire savoir et arrêtons
d'être négatif et pessimistes notamment
dans les médias pour dire partout que
tout est foutu ma pauvre dame classe je
suis désolé de cette expression mais
c'est un peu le sentiment que j'ai on ne
parle jamais des réussites de mise en
place des rythmes dans certains endroits
donc voilà les sachons faire passer nos
messages et sachons faire savoir ce qui
va bien donc le projet d'établissement
la précipitation et est mauvaise les
projets d'établissement ont été oubliés
mais laissons le temps de se réadapter
de remettre en place des choses qui et
qui fonctionnerait beaucoup mieux
alors je crois aussi que dans le
périscolaire et là les communes
interviennent et
et tant mieux parce que c'est aussi les
enfants de leur commune quelqu'un l'a
évoqué je le dis très souvent moi aussi
les enfants d'aujourd'hui sont la
société demain dans qu'est ce que l'on
fait nous adultes responsables pour que
nos enfants réussissent leur scolarité
qu'est ce que font les communes pour
adapter au mieux les rythmes scolaires
pour que les enfants qu'ils ont dans
leur commune aujourd'hui soit les
citoyens et pourquoi pas les élus de
demain et que ce soit des adultes
épanouis et responsable et bien souvent
il y à des inégalités de traitement
entre
certaines communes et certains
établissements il ya des communes qui
ont des moyens ou qui ont voulu se
donner les moyens pour la réussite de
ces rythmes et d'autres qui vont
frileusement d'autres qui entendent plus
le message des enseignants ou de
certains parents qui sont vent debout
contre la réforme dans leur intérêt
personnel et n'entendent pas forcément
les associations de parents d'élèves et
puis il ya aussi cette alors ce qui ne
concerne que l'enseignement catholique
nous rencontrons les fonds d'amorçage
qui ont été mis en place par les
communes enfin rendue obligatoire 50 ou
90 euros dans l'enseignement catholique
nous avons parfois dans certains
endroits des difficultés pour obtenir
ces fonds d'amorçage certaines communes
se font un peu tirer l'oreille pour les
versés aux établissements de
l'enseignement catholique des
établissements sous contrat
d'association
voilà je crois que pour conclure et je
laisserai la parole à christophe
rapidement pour essayer de ne pas
dépasser le temps de parole je crois que
c'est vraiment la concertation le
dialogue prendre le temps de réfléchir
sur un vrai projet un vrai projet en
lien avec l'établissement avec le projet
éducatif de l'établissement laisser
l'autonomie
l'autonomie la liberté aux chefs
d'établissement à son équipe à toute la
communauté éducative pour mettre en
place de vrais projets et ne pas hésiter
à les corriger à les modifier en
fonction que de ce qui correspond le
mieux aux enfants et ce qui sera le
meilleur pour l'enfant dans le travail
on travaille on et gardons à l'esprit
sachant faire passer ce message que
c'est l'intérêt de l'enfant avant tout
et pas celui des parents est pas celui
des enseignants il compte aussi il
compte bien évidemment que la vie de
famille équilibrée compte bien
évidemment qu'un enseignant qui se sent
bien dans son travail qui était pas nous
y sera un bon enseignant et que si on
l'obligé à venir travailler dans un
établissement sous une réforme sous des
rythmes qui ne lui conviennent pas mais
sachons dialoguer mettre en place de
beaux projets pour nos enfants
justement parce que vous l'avez dit il
est important surtout qu'on ait un
dialogue juste deux mots parce que
caroline sayoud a de toute façon à 10 10
le plus important je voulais simplement
assister donc sur dire que toutes les
difficultés tiennent haut à la
communication
finalement ils ont le toutes les
fédérations de parents d'élèves le
réclame régulièrement il n'y a pas assez
de communication entre les parents et
les enseignants et les chefs
d'établissement donc pourquoi là ce
serait facile tout d'un coup sur un
sujet qui nécessite une communication et
cette communication et ses sens est
essentielle et il n'y a pas assez de
communication entre le monde scolaire et
les communes donc là aussi cette
communication est essentielle donc il ya
un deuxième écueil
je n'insisterai donc sur deux points
parce que parce que c'est des points
vous parfois nous avons un désaccord
il nous semble pour l'heure pour les
appels capital qu'il y ait un lien entre
les enseignants et les personnes en
charge à qui on confiera le périscolaire
de notre côté nous n'imaginons pas deux
mondes un kir est de 8h30 à 15h30 avec
des enseignants et tout d'un coup les
élèves qui sont passés à d'autres
personnes et que ses responsables ces
personnes qui qui font un acte éducatif
quels qu'ils soient qui accompagne les
jeunes ne travaillent pas ensemble ne
sera pas connecté pour nous ce n'est pas
envisageable il faut que ce périscolaire
soit lui aussi raccrocher au projet
d'établissement il faut que les
personnes puissent travailler ensemble
enfin le financement
c'est un point évidemment sur lequel
nous n'étions pas tout à fait d'accord
vous l'avez bien compris on remercie
dans ce projet le gouvernement de
l'avoir compris et d'avoir mis un fonds
d'amorçage qui est à disposition de
l'enseignement public et de
l'enseignement associés par contre à
l'état puisque évidemment là ce sont les
enfants et c'est le même les mêmes
enfants le périscolaire les mêmes
besoins on serait très heureux que les
communes envisage la chose de la même
façon ce sont leurs enfants les enfants
de leur commune ils ont exactement les
mêmes besoins et à partir du moment où
on souhaite que les uns et les autres
s'engagent vers une réforme fondamentale
et encore une fois caroline l'a dit la
réforme fondamentale c'est la partie
scolaire qu'ils aient plus de temps pour
les fondamentaux qu'ils aient plus de
temps pour apprendre mais qu'ils aient
aussi ce périscolaire qui leur permet
une autre ouverture qui leur permettent
de mettre en avant d'autres qualités de
découvrir
d'une manière différente la culture le
sport etc eh bien tous les enfants là
vous vous reconnaîtrez j'espère les
enfants sont les mêmes ils ont les mêmes
besoins donc nous attendons des
collectivités territoriales est ici au
sénat nous devions le dire nous
attendions des collectivités
territoriales à un traitement équitable
dame s'allier au monsieur abraham merci
de cette contribution nous allons passer
maintenant à aux questions si vous en
êtes d'accord madame le rapporteur va
vous poser une série de questions aux
uns et aux autres auquel vous allez
pouvoir répondre immédiatement
ensuite ce sont les collègues qui
poseront les questions de façon
simultanée et nous les prendrons donc
ensemble et ensuite vous pourrez
répondre à l'ensemble des questions des
sénateurs alors la parole est à madame
le rapporteur
merci beaucoup madame la présidente
alors je vais d'abord faire jeudi une
petite réaction
je ne vivrai une petite réflexion par
rapport à ce que les uns et les autres
vous avez pu dire de votre statut de
deux parents d'élèves et
j'ai envie de dire que
je perçois un certain nombre de
contradictions
alors je m'explique bon tout d'abord
tout le monde le reconnaît
le bien fondé de cette réforme qui dont
on parle depuis des années des années
des années donc ça c'est c'est une
première chose mais
ensuite quand je parle de première
contradiction
vous avez évoqué madame
saliou
que pour le bien de l'enfant le samedi
matin uts été un meilleur choix alors je
vous le dis en plus très spontanément je
le partage mais la contradiction
apparaît tout de suite puisqu'il ya la
demande des parents d'élèves de dit
d'être associé donc qu'on fait les
collectivités
et qu'est ce qu'on aurait dit si elle
n'avait pas consulté les parents et
quand on consulte les parents
90% des réponses sont pour le mercredi
matin dont la une première contradiction
comment gères
comment on gère ce que on peut avoir
comme vous le dites la conviction que le
samedi matin c'est mieux pour l'enfant
mais on se sent aujourd'hui dans une
société où le dialogue est demandé la
concertation les changes que dès qu'on
consulte alors il y à ce que vous avez
dit c'est là je renvoie jeudi a sans
doute un travail pédagogique à faire
deux par les associations pour
amener une réflexion auprès des parents
et pour faire que la réponse qu'ils font
est souvent une réponse peut-être de
deux je sais même pas si cette facilité
parce qu'aujourd'hui il ya des
difficultés à certains endroits parce
que les parents voient bien que des
activités qui étaient mis en place ou
désorganisation de mercredi sont
bousculés par le mercredi matin et que
finalement le samedi matin ce n'aurait
pas été plus mal mais là encore on a je
dire on a répondu avant d'avoir
peut-être travailler la question
c'est pour cela que je vous pose la
question qui en découle est ce que dans
vos organisations vous travaillez à la
réfection de la rue nation de l'année
parce que vous dites c'est vrai il
faudrait il faudrait tout faire mais bon
quand on voit
ce que a provoqué
juste le chargement d'une demi journée
j'imagine ce que va pouvoir provoquer un
raccourcissement des vacances d'été
parce que là on ira vers la main d'or 20
donc est ce que vous y travailler parce
que tout le monde est d'accord pour
raccourcir mais pas au même endroit par
même moment et puis on va poser d'autres
questions et le bac et tout un tas de
choses donc deuxième question voilà
parce que on peut lancer mais est ce que
justement et je pense qu'il faudrait
faire ce travail en amont avant à 20
avant de se lancer
deuxième contradiction donc que j'ai
pointé
et est ce que là aussi vous avez un
travail
auprès des parents d'élèves parce que il
ya eu de la confusion souvent entre
cette réforme des rythmes et où on a dit
mais finalement la journée elle est pas
l epa raccourcis maintenant elle peut
pas être raccourcies puisse la journée
ce temps social des parents donc dire
faire porter une responsabilité au reed
man 10 ans mais finalement les enfants
les journées sont aussi l'inde ah oui
alors est-ce qu'il ya aussi un travail
par rapport à l'organique qui n'est pas
facile par rapport à l'organisation du
temps de travail des familles et
deuxième question que je pose c'est
peut-être un peu trop tôt est ce que
vous avez pu vous une évaluation est ce
qu'il y a eu du fait de l'introduction
d'une matinée de classe travail et un
changement
dans l'organisation du temps des parents
peut-être même d'avoir des femmes
puisque on a entendu parler que des
personnes avaient recommencé à
travailler alors qu'elle avait un temps
partiel avec le mercredi totalement
livre qu'elle avait recommencé où
étaient passés les méthodes de 80 à 90%
est-ce que sur ça vous avez des
indications et est ce que ça peut être
aussi une piste d'évaluation pour vous
auprès de auprès de vos auprès de vos
adhérents
ensuite autre contradiction on parle
beaucoup
des activités d'étape or tout le monde
et je crois que même les parents disent
mais il faut du temps à l'enfant pour
souffler il faut du temps pour ne rien
faire mais on est dans la revendication
dans l'exigence toujours plus
d'activités avec toujours plus de
personnes formées c'est à dire penser
qu'un enfant peut être au coin à la
médiathèque en train de tranquillement
regarder un livre ça va pas apparaître
comme une activité parce qu'il n'aura
pas l'animateur qui peut être lui fera
résumer le livre c'est pas ça donc
parfois j'entends une confusion entre le
mot pédagogique j'ai entendu beaucoup
employé et c'est du temps éducatif c'est
pas forcément dis donc donc on ne peut
pas avoir donc après les exigences en
termes d'encadrement en termes de
formation en termes de tout ça c'est pas
les mêmes or tous les pédopsychiatres
bien que l'enfant a besoin aussi de
souffler de rêver et se construit aussi
bien qu'avec une activité toujours très
structuré voilà et donc
je voulais poser une question donc à
l'appel un peu parce que j'ai par de
hesc comment analysez vous le fais bon
on est on a eu des représentants
l'enseignement catholique tout à l'heure
qui nous en dit peu d'écoles 10% des
écoles d'enseignement catholique sont
passés au rythme et il avait l'air
pessimiste pour la prochaine rentrée
donc est-ce que vous participez à ce
pessimisme est ce que vous dites vous
pensez que et comment année analysez
vous le faites
parce que moi j'avoue que là je suis un
peu étonné parce que souvent dans
l'enseignement catholique a eu des
initiatives
d'organisation de temps différent du
fait aussi de l'autonomie qu'on les
établissements je pensais qu'il était en
condition et justement en condition pour
être beaucoup plus libres sens et donc
beaucoup plus allants donc comment
expliquez vous
cette peut-être cette cette frilosité et
enfin tout le monde on a pointé la
nécessité
de l'articulation temps scolaire hors
temps scolaire après il ya des
interrogations à la place des
collectivités est ce que c'est j'ai
retenu c'est sûr que les collectivités
font pas de pédagogique
fang l'éducatif mais ça c'est le rôle
c'est le rôle d'une société et voilà je
je je m'arrêterai là j'aurais on verrait
à ce proverbe africain que vous devez
connaître il faut tout un village pour
bien éduquer un enfant et je crois que
la réforme des rimes c'est sans doute ça
et c'est sans doute ce qu'il faut
essayer de faire
merci beaucoup madame le rapporteur
voilà un beau bouquet de questions après
donc je à votre convenance qui sait
qu'ils souhaitent malam kojak en premier
rapidement revenir sont effectivement
sur cette organisation sur le
l'organisation du temps des enfants sur
la semaine le mois l'année c'est
effectivement nous a laissé peu une
question qu'on se pose depuis longtemps
qu'on revendique depuis longtemps une
alternance de sept semaines de classe
deux semaines de repos parce qu'on sait
que les deux semaines sont nécessaires
pour que ce soit des vraies vacances
bon quand ça oui ça on y est on a en a
un là dessus on s'est quand même une
avancée légère il faut quand même
continuer à être vigilant parce que on a
vu qu'à un moment il y avait deux
semaines par un peu je sais plus sur
quelqu'un de lacan ce qu'apprend on
était revenu en arrière notamment sur
les vacances d'automne qui ont beaucoup
varié dont il ya quand même une certaine
vigilance à avoir par amp sur ce ne
serait ce que ces vacances qui est un
moment dure une semaine dix jours qu'un
jour enfin c'est acté un peu donc il ya
effectivement si la reconquête du mois
de juin alors on a parlé dans notre
intervention sur le collégiens et les
lycéens qui ont des rythmes de vie et de
rythmes scolaires qui sont souvent très
intense avec des départs notamment sur
les territoires ruraux très tôt le matin
des retours très tard alors quand on dit
35 eur ttc
c'est bien que on voit bien que nos
enfants ont souvent nos jeunes
collégiens lycéens ont vraiment des
semaines à rallonge et ont des temps
notamment par le fait des devoirs à la
maison alors effectivement pour les
collégiens et lycéens
ça peut poser interrogations mais que ce
temps parce que parents nous sur les
devoirs en primaire on est très très
clair pas de devoirs à la maison il ya
d'autres moyens de communiquer avec
l'école que par l'intermédiaire des
devoirs c'est de la sous traitance
pédagogique nous ne sommes des parents
d'élèves nous ne sommes pas en saignant
moi je viens nous ne sommes pas en
capacité de forcément bien accompagner
notre enfant dans des apprentissages
fondamentaux les méthodes
d'apprentissage ont changé que de la
façon dont je donnerai un exemple la
division quand nous on l'a appris
maintenant nos enfants ils n'apprennent
plus de la même façon alors quand on est
parent d'élève ce n'est pas évident
notamment aussi souvent quand on est un
peu les moyens de l'école d'aller
demander des conseils etc donc c'est
bien que les devoirs c'est pas à la
maison qu'il faut les faire le texte est
sain oui mais les devoirs d'un art est
fait à l'école
abbey voilà on est le problème
après sur effectivement les
contradictions qui peut y avoir entre ce
que ce qui serait l'idéal pour les
enfants des jeux d'hier est l'intérêt
la dichotomie entre l'intérêt de
l'enfant et l'intérêt particulier des
adultes quand je dis les adultes je dis
bien nous tous adultes effectivement et
est difficile alors on voit qu'il ya des
endroits où il ya eu la moins mauvaise
des solutions parce qu'effectivement il
faut concilier notamment je reviendrai
sur les territoires ruraux quand il ya
des déplacements acceptera des
organisations mais quand ça se fait dans
la concertation
enfin nous ça ne nous pose aucun pas de
problème parce que justement la
concertation va permettre de construire
parce que souvent on voit que quand il
ya des concertations quand il ya un
comité de mise en place il ya eu un
chronobiologistes qui est venu expliquer
ce que c'était les rythmes ya eu de la
formation départ de tous les acteurs de
la communauté éducative et à ceux partir
de là on arrive à trouver des solutions
il ya effectivement sur cette pause
méridienne ce qu'on sait qu'il ya des
des pics de vigilance à des endroits où
ils ont bien compris alors il y avait
bon on ne peut pas mettre deux heures et
demie parce que pour les questions
d'organisation
donc on va trouver une solution qui va
me permettre que les apprentissages
fondamentaux enfin les apprentissages
scolaires on parle bien du temps
scolaire se fasse à des heures où
l'enfant va être plus vigilants on voit
bien que quand il ya eu cette ce
dialogue c'est pédagogie cette
explication sur le pourquoi on
réorganise ce temps d'apprentissage
parce que je crois qu'il faut vraiment
public c'est bien un temps sur l'école
après les temps d'activités
périscolaires c'est pas cette réforme là
qui est en place effectivement il ya
d'autres choix et comme une ode
intercommunaux les intercommunalités
pardon qui doivent faire les voire même
pourquoi pas les départements on
pourrait vous allez plus loin les
régions etc donc c'est bien sûr c'est un
vrai quand on explique on l'a vu dans
dans des noms je viens d'un territoire
mais quand on l'a expliqué eh ben on
arrive mieux à aller vers quelque chose
alors c'est pas forcément le samedi
matin c'est pas forcément c'est aussi
des fois que ça nous va bien très peu de
communes ont choisi ces 34 34 communes
ont choisi mais je crois qu'il ya aussi
et plat les chronobiologistes g tous
d'accord sur dire que c'est la
rythmicité qui compte alors mercredi
matin samedi matin nous sur cette
position n'a pas de position la via des
que certains chronobiologistes qu'il
faudrait qu'ils aient six jours d'école
pour respecter cette rythmicité vous
voyez je crois qu'il faut aussi écouter
ces gens qui ont travaillé il ya des
psychologues les médecins enfin les
académies de médecine ont un certain
nombre d'avis qui nous sommes important
d'écouter d'expliquer mais c'est pas
toujours évident de mettre son intérêt
particulier d'adultes
en retrait de l'intérêt particulier de
tous les enfants je dirais
si madame kojak d'autres interventions
pour des une réponse à madame le
rapporteur
madame marty ensuite madame saliou
oui concernant la contradiction du
samedi matin est bien dans certains cas
la concertation était fait la communauté
éducative dans certains cas choisi le
samedi matin et le maire a choisi le
mercredi voilà donc il ya eu des
contradictions effectivement à vouloir
consulter parfois on avait des
contradictions qui sont assez étonnantes
moi j'ai trouvé néanmoins ce qui s'avère
c'est que les mairies qui sont passés en
2013 et les parents actuellement qui ont
mis en place la demi journée au niveau
du mercredi s'interroge sur le samedi
comme quoi comme quoi je pense qu' il
fallait du temps pour discuter il
fallait du temps pour mettre en oeuvre
cette réforme et je pense
qu'effectivement en mettant du temps et
en faisant en réfléchissant sur
l'articulation et cetera on se rend
compte qu a effectivement à un moment
donné le samedi patins parfois dans
certaines communes dans certains il y
avait consensus on aurait pu arriver à
un consensus et c'est dommage parce que
bon c'était aussi une solution qui est
moins onéreuse aussi en plus en plus qui
déstabilisent - les associations le
tissu associatif et cetera donc voilà
c'est un petit peu dommage et puis le
cadre je regrette aussi au niveau du
décret c'est que le samedi matin et est
dérogatoire voilà donc ça un petit peu
poussé certains maires qui ont dit bah
non je comprends pas très bien donc
voilà un peu plus de temps une meilleure
visibilité du enfin une meilleure
lisibilité et compréhension du cadre
dans lequel on était aurait permis
peut-être de passer au samedi matin
c'est dommage parce que c'est
effectivement
une organisation intéressante pour les
familles pour les rencontres etc etc
voilà donc ça c'est les contradictions
qui ne lançons pas réellement je dirais
concernant raccourcissement des vacances
d'été ben nous on a fait des sondages
les parents sont ils sont favorables les
parents sont favorables ceux qui sont
pas favorables ce sont les enseignants
donc nous notre côté nous sommes
d'accord pour lé raccourcissement des
vacances d'été nous sommes contre le
zonage des vacances d'été par contre
voilà alors que les professionnels du
tourisme mais oui mais que les
professionnels qu'à un moment donné moi
je veux bien mais à chaque fois on nous
demande et puis on nous dit oui mais les
professions du tourisme dit c'est un
problème etc oui mais à un moment donné
les vacances d'été c'est les vacances où
effectivement les familles se
rassemblent en voilà donc un moment
donné c'est pareil pour pour
l'alternance du 7 2 bat on peut arriver
à une véritable alternance entre cette
semaine travailler 2 de congés que si et
seulement si on enlève une 3 une zone
parce que sur les trois autres forcément
au bout d'un moment il y en a une qui
fait pas cette semaine c'est évident
c'est mathématique donc nous avons
effectivement c'est pareil après on nous
dit oui mais pour le ski c'est un
problème voilà après il faut ça voilà
bon bon donc voilà effectivement on se
retrouve avec la quadrature du cercle
qui fait qu'à un moment donné
effectivement on est coincé si on prend
les contraintes et voilà donc c'est
c'est un petit peu la problématique des
ses vacances mais je pense que les
parents sont à voile j'ai laissé ma
colère est bon
alors rapidement sur le travail des
femmes alors il ya deux choses déjà
c'est que bien souvent la décision de
mettre en place les quatre jours et demi
a été tardive or les demandes de
modification de temps partiel se font en
jean 20 décembre pour janvier donc
effectivement les femmes qui le font
maintenant le souhait on l'a
effectivement d'un certain nombre de
femmes qui nous ont dit clairement que
pour elle ça allait pouvoir être
l'opportunité de pouvoir passer à 90
même 100% avec le souci malgré tout
c'est que dans certaines communes et
bien c'est fin de l'école mercredi midi
rien derrière donc pas de cantine ou pas
de liaison avec le centre de loisirs
parce qu'elle n'avait pas parce que dans
certaines communes aussi les centres de
loisirs ne sont pas à proximité des
écoles c'est vrai que dans les communes
où c'est parce que c'est pas un reproche
mais bien organisés depuis toujours les
choses se sont mises en place et là
effectivement on sait qu'il ya un
certain nombre de mamans qui vont faire
une demande à revenir sur des temps pour
d'autres elles font le choix de rester à
80% mais de réduire du coup leur journée
pouvoir rentrer plus tôt pour leurs
enfants donc on a un peu les deux cas
malgré tout maintenant faire du
chiffrage c'est un petit peu compliqué
puisque toute façon pour la plupart
d'entre elles il fallait qu'elle attende
décembre pour faire une demande de
modification
même sur leur temps partiel de le
répartir leurs 80 % et contrairement à
ce qu'on pourrait espérer est souhaitée
les entreprises sont pas du tout
flexible ne sont pas du tout dans l'
écoute de ce genre de problématique et
ça c'est vrai qu'avant qu'on va changer
ces mentalités là en période d'extrême
crise où les charrettes pleuvent à tire
larigot c'est vrai que c'est compliqué
faut être honnête
alors sur l'étape c'est vrai que très
rapidement excusé nous c'est vrai que
c'est une réforme des rythmes et pas une
réforme du périscolaire mais c'est vrai
aussi que pour vendre la réforme on a
clairement dit aux parents vous allez
avoir des activités on va mettre en
place on va développer des choses que
vos enfants n'ont pas d'habitude et le
problème c'est qu'on a passé moi
l'expression on a vendu un aspirateur
alors qu'en réalité on était venu pour
une machine à laver excusez moi en
faisant ça mais c'est un petit peu ça
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on est sur
une réforme des rythmes qui s'est
transformée en une réforme des des
options possibles à la sortie de l'école
et c'est vrai qu il faudrait il faut des
temps de calme pour les enfants et en
même temps il n'ya pas toujours les
locaux
quand vous êtes dans les grosses écoles
où il n'ya déjà aucune structure et où
il faut déjà faire faire les activités
dans les salles de classe il est clair
qu'on ne peut pas proposer un temps
calme dans une salle de classe à part en
disant aux enfants croiser les bras
mettait la tête dessus et attendait tous
donc c'est vrai que ces temps calme
finalement on en a besoin les lieux ne
sont pas toujours le personnel non plus
et du coup c'est sûr activité qui
effectivement fatigue énormément les
enfants quelque part on était une grosse
couche de maquillage mais à terme il
faudra il faudra remettre un peu d'ordre
dans tout ça parce qu'effectivement
fatigue les enfants voulant bien faire
on ne leur accorde pas les temps calmes
dont ils ont besoin mais ces temps calme
pour les avoir il faut parfois aussi
restructurer un peu les écoles recréer
des endroits parce qu'il y en a mais
c'est vrai qu'on a aussi pris de
mauvaises habitudes dans les écoles il
ya un bien besoin de réflexion c'est
pour ça qu'il fallait aussi un peu de
temps parce que parfois il faudrait
aussi s'asseoir regarder tous les locaux
prendre les plans et regarder comment on
pourrait reconfigurer l'école parfois on
pourra pas du tout la reconfigurer
soyons honnêtes parce qu'avec les
montées d'effectifs eh ben on a ouvert
des classes partout où on pouvait bien
souvent vous avez quand même dans les
grandes villes il n'ya même plus de bcd
il ya plus de salles de sciences il ya
plus aucune salle même pas pour des
activités qui sont normalement prévues
dans les programmes donc impossible
effectivement de créer plus c'est de
faire plus à ce niveau là et puis malgré
tout c'est vrai que ça aurait pu être
aussi une opportunité de créer un vrai
diplôme une vraie formation diplômante
de l'encadrement périscolaire où
justement on aurait pu bien définir les
miss on bien dire qu'elle clairement ce
que c'était ça aurait évité que l'on
confonde pédagogique culturel enfin tous
en même temps et ça aurait évité aussi
aujourd'hui le fait qu'on prend un petit
peu n'importe qui n'importe quand qu'on
ne pérennise pas les emplois que ces
gens là on leur propose des emplois très
précaire donc il ne reste pas il va
falloir à terme re réfléchir aussi
réellement ceux là dessus parce que là
si on veut d'étape de qualité il faut
des gens qui ont eu un minimum de
formation à la gestion du groupe à la
gestion à l'encadrement des enfants tous
les enfants fonction des âges n'ont pas
les mêmes besoins effectivement si
aujourd'hui on a des problèmes de
règlement intérieur c'est parce que
finalement ces personnes là ne sont pas
habitués au fait qui puisse y avoir un
règlement intérieur une tenue vis-à-vis
des enfants combien de fois on nous on
nous signale les portables les choses il
faut effectivement qu'on ait une unité
dans l'école dans le fonctionnement de
l'école et ça ça passera par tout ça
merci beaucoup je voudrais juste
rajouter sans ouvrir le débat on peut en
parler tout à l'heure c'est que les
communes qui ont des périscolaires et
qui ont des contrats avec la caf sont
obligés de mettre à disposition de
d'embaucher des animateurs formés à
minima b b le barça ou le bafd a minima
voilà donc madame saliou est ensuite
madame fontaine
merci donc également une réponse à deux
voix alors sur sur la contradiction que
vous avez évoquées bien évidemment que
je partage votre propos nous avons sans
doute nous la chance fédération de
parents associations de parents d'être
au coeur des débats d'être au coeur des
expériences d'être en relation avec les
experts donc nous en sommes convaincus
de ce samedi matin alors avec les
réserves qui vont avec puisque dans
certains endroits ça n'est pas possible
et ce serait même plutôt négatif avec
certaines aides mais la semaine qui
pourrait être la meilleure ce serait
effectivement le samedi matin nous avons
une grande responsabilité
association de parents à informer nos
parents est allé qu'on a alors je pense
que depuis toutes ces années que don
depuis que l'on parle des rythmes
scolaires il ya une évolution vous
parlez de la consultation qui a été fait
ou en majorité les parents ont choisi le
mercredi alors je pense qu'il ya un
manque d'information certes mais il ya
quand même une évolution parce que cette
enquête nous l'avions déjà fait il ya
quasiment une dizaine d'années et
c'était effectivement le samedi matin
supprimés dans l'anc est de cette année
si les parents sont toujours pour le
samedi matin supprimés et 20 n'ont
travaillé un certain nombre de parents
ont pris conscience quand même et je
pense qu'il ya une évolution oui mais ça
n'empêche pas notre responsabilité à
nous parents de
d'informer de dialoguer d'aller alors
d'où l'importance des associations de
parents d'élèves et nous encore une fois
nous sommes conscients en tant
qu'association nationale et sans doute
au niveau des régions et des
départements
mais dans les établissements les
associations de parents se sentent plus
ont des difficultés à avoir cette
démarche cette réflexion il se sent plus
animateur d'établissement que ils sont
moins à l'aise dans le champ éducatif
ils ont moins la possibilité peut-être
enfin voilà ils ont moins tendance à
aller chercher les informations qui les
aideraient dans leur rôle de président
après je soutiendrai ce qu'a dit valérie
marty tout à l'heure dans certains
endroits le samedi matin a été choisi et
le maire a choisi le mercredi siens et
je vais vous dire nul n'est prophète en
son pays puisque dans la commune de 1800
habitants mayenne où mon mari est
adjoint au maire chargé des affaires
scolaires
le groupe de travail de mon mari avait
dit samedi matin le maire s'est opposée
ce sera mercredi matin à partir de la
prochaine année prochaine donc alors il
ya des élections entre temps
marie un dilemme ne l'a mon mari est
candidat
mais je peux vous dire que nana mais
j'ai une commune de 1800 habitants c'est
à dire une petite commune on se connaît
tous nous habitons là depuis 25 ans tout
le monde me connaît le maire compris et
le débat sur les rythmes scolaires nous
l'avons depuis et je suis à l'intérieur
de ce débat depuis plus de 15 18 ans et
bien sûr madame ça lieu dans la commune
dont vous parlez la nuit la vôtre les
enseignants sont pour le samedi ou pour
le mercredi mais alors ils sont partagés
je n'oserais pas dire qu'elle est parce
qu il ya deux écoles une public une
privée tout le monde travaille en grande
concertation mais bon voilà je voudrais
pas répondre à cette question je que
monsieur le maire a pris le parti des
enseignants
non il a pris un parti qui pour lui et
économique et qui est un mauvais calcul
il n'a pas pris le parti des enseignants
et il a il a alors il a pris à partie
économique et il a pris un parti de la
préconisation
de
l'inspecteur d'académie
donc voilà c'est donc voilà on a mais
voilà je peux vous dire que dans une
commune où je suis impliqué où je
développe on m'a demandé d'intervenir
sur les rythmes scolaires je ne suis pas
entendu donc voilà c'est nul n'est
prophète en son pays sur le donc je
confirme qu'on a un gros travail à faire
auprès des parents sachent je vous
l'accordé vous avez entièrement raison
de l'affirmer et de d'enfoncer le clou
sur le travail enfin des femmes qui
auraient pu reprendre le travail nous
n'avons aucune donnée c'est vrai que ça
n'est pas remonté dans le groupe de
travail qui a été mis en place au sein
de l'enseignement catholique par contre
il ya une réflexion que moi j'avais
soumise au départ et que l'on n'a pas
gardé peut-être que je ne me suis pas
suffisamment attaché je m'étais dit
puisque enfin dans le groupe de travail
j'avais dit mais est ce qu'on pourrait
pas réfléchir à aller vers les
entreprises puisque ces femmes qui ne
qui ne travaillait pas le mercredi pour
pouvoir s'occuper des enfants si elle
reprenait le travail mais finissait plus
tôt dans la journée est ce qu'on
pourrait pas voir vers les entreprises
si quelque chose ne se voit là c'était
une simple réflexion mais pour autant il
n'y a pas eu de suite et j'en suis en
partie responsable parce qu'on ne s'est
pas penché sur ce volet là et puis vous
avez évoqué la frilosité de
l'enseignement catholique alors ça n'est
absolument pas une frileuse frilosité je
ne sais pas ce qu'on pu dire nos
collègues et amis des syndicats ce que
nous n'avons pas voulu
c'est dans le cadre de notre liberté de
notre autonomie c'est aller dans la
précipitation ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que les établissements donc moins
de 10 % c'est vrai mais les
établissements qui sont passés un de
vrais projets devraient réalisation et
de vrais résultats
et nous avons organisé donc le 17
janvier prochain la selle donc la
semaine prochaine une grande journée sur
les rythmes scolaires où tous les
départements les régions sont invités
enseignement catholique pour continuer à
travailler à voir quels sont les projets
les possibilités
partager échanger pour aller vers sans
doute parce que tout le monde est
conscient pour y aller mais y aller au
rythme de chacun en s'adaptant à
l'établissement à la commune à la
collectivité à la région où nous nous
trouvons voilà on on encourage on donne
un cadre on est on encourage d'abord à
la réflexion est un vrai projet que nous
n'allions pas dans l'art et dans la
précipitation et surtout ce sur quoi on
assiste à chaque fois sur scène et on
assistera le 17 janvier c'est sur cette
réforme qui serait une réforme
périscolaire c'est pas ça la réforme des
rythmes scolaires donc voila et
christophe complétera sur les autres
questions parce que c'est des questions
qui ont été évoquées au sein du groupe
de travail sur ce point là nous avons
tous cru dans les débats précédents que
nous étions tous d'accord parce que nous
avions une culture parce que nous en
avions parlé depuis des années mais
personne n'a vu à quel point le sujet
pouvait être complexe il combien il
pouvait y avoir d'interprétations
différentes et cette réforme a été
imposée je suis désolé de le dire mais
imposée avec un a
il a cru oui non mais c'est pour ça que
je dis nous avons aussi bien ministère
nous tous donc on a cru et quand il ya
eu les débats au moment de la
concertation on a cru que c'était
quelque chose d'évident mais il faut
pour que cette réforme soit réussie que
chacun comprenne l'intérêt de cette
réforme or on ne peut pas la comprendre
s'il n'y a pas des débats au niveau
local cette réforme concerne tous les
acteurs de la communauté éducative
il doit donc y avoir un débat dans
l'ordre dans chaque communauté éducative
si on ne prend pas ce temps là la
communauté éducative s'approprie pas la
réforme ne la comprend pas et chacun
reste donc sur son pré carré voilà pour
cette pour ce point là sur la partie est
ce que est ce que nous envisageons
attend enfin une réforme du temps du
rythme annuel oui et nous y travaillons
l'aparté et nous pensons que cette
réforme pourrait être finalisée que si
il y à aussi une réforme des rythmes
annuels par contre là pour le coup nous
avons un problème autant nous sommes
n'avons plus de liberté sur
l'organisation de la semaine
la chance va dire ça alors sagement
catholique autant nous en avons moins
sur le rythme annuel et je ne suis pas
aussi pessimiste que vous parce que si
nous nous rappelons la ve en 2008 il y
avait beaucoup plus de deux cas
différents et il y avait nombre de
départements qui avaient réduit par
exemple le temps des grandes vacances
dans l'enseignement catholique le quart
des établissements étaient a déjà la
semaine des quatre jours sauf que ce
n'était pas du tout la même semaine des
quatre jours c'était une semaine des
quatre jours où effectivement il y avait
plus de jours de classe parce que l'on
réduisait les autres vacances or on nous
a imposé quelque chose depuis la rue de
grenelle avec un même exemple valable
pour l'ensemble du territoire nous
sommes ça ne vous étonnera pas
complètement opposé à ce schéma nous
voulons plus d'autonomie plus de
souplesse je vous donnerai qu'un seul
exemple chacun prend ses exemples locaux
mais celui ci je connais bien en tant
qu'ancien normands en normandie vous
savez qu on coupe la poire en deux donc
il y avait nombre d'écoles qui ont mis
le samedi travailler une fois sur deux
et bien aujourd'hui on ne peut plus le
faire ça or ce samedi travailler une
fois sur deux permettait à la fois aux
familles qui qui avait eu un divorce qui
est bien de laisser l'enfant plus libres
d'aller chez le deuxième conjoint et
permettait aussi aux familles de venir
plus facilement dans l'école parce
qu'une fois sur deux le samedi matin
était travaillé et on pouvait se
retrouver parce que nombre de deux
parents ne travaillent pas tous mais
nombre de parents ne travaillent pas le
samedi matin donc ça c'est un exemple de
souplesse que nous n'avons plus
aujourd'hui parce que si nous voulons
réduire le temps scolaire sur l'année il
nous faut une dérogation qui depuis 2008
nous est refusé alors que nous en avons
fait au niveau de l'appel la demande des
la réforme de 2008 oui donc oui nous
souhaitons poursuivre cette réforme des
rythmes sur le côté annualisation fans
le rythme annuel parce que le rythme de
l'enfant
c'est ça qui est important et le rythme
de l'enfant s'est pas rythme de la
journée c'est le rythme aussi là avec
les parents c'est le rythme sur
l'ensemble de l'année c'est au rythme
des vacances
merci monsieur abraham je vais donner la
parole à madame fond madame kojak ou
souhaitiez tout réagir tout à l'heure
peut-être après madame fontaine très
rapidement une petite réaction c'est
vrai qu'en 2008 on nous a imposé la
semaine des quatre jours
sans faire de provocation inutile
personne n'at il n'y a pas eu de gros
bronca ça n'a pas été la révolution
tout le monde l'a acceptée effectivement
il y avait des organisations des
départements où il y avait un tout tout
non non on a entendu peu de peu de
personnes protester
par rapport à voile à par rapport à
l'ampleur callable qu'il y a et sur ce
sujet qui me devrai qui faisait quand
même rappelons je vais me permettre de
rappeler qu'il faisait quand même
consensus pour dire que la semaine de
quatre jours c'était pas bon quand on
voit maintenant quand on vous dit qu'on
va revenir à ses quelque chose qui est
meilleur pour l'enfant le on a
l'impression de faire la révolution la
révolution pour nous ça a été en 2008
quand on est passé en semaine de quatre
jours et ça ça a été une vraie
révolution
bien merci madame fontaine c'est tabou
merci donc concernant le samedi matin
travaillé nous quand on avait parlé
justement de cette réforme nous sommes
allés à plusieurs entretiens si vous
vous souvenez bien ce que nous avions
prenez c'était maintenir les quatre
jours à réduire ces fameuses vacances
ces grandes vacances parce que la
plupart des familles pendant huit
semaines huit semaines c'est long mais
ce qu'on avait dit et je me je reviens
avec valérie on avait dit qu'il fallait
arrêter de faire trois zonage 3 zonage
parce que ce qui signifiait que parfois
des familles reconstituées qui sont sur
deux communes différentes très proches
pouvaient avoir ne pas être ensemble
pendant ces vacances là donc c'est pour
ça qu'on avait demandé de rester à de
zonage
nous pensions effectivement que s'il y
avait un choix à faire et nous le
souhaitions pas à l'époque s'il y avait
un choix à faire que c'était le samedi
qu'ils étaient meilleurs pourquoi parce
que qu'est ce qui se passe côté urbain
le samedi vous avez pas beaucoup
d'orthophonistes orthodontiste qui
travail etc et c'est vrai la vraie croix
et la bannière pour les familles pour
emmener les enfants pour avoir un vrai
suivi donc là avec le mercredi matin qui
est pris mais je peux vous assurer que
les parents autour de nous qui ont des
problèmes de suivi médico pour leurs
enfants ou de pédopsychiatres et ben là
seront obligés de s'organiser
moi j'ai la chance de faire partie d'un
gros groupe je travaille à plein-temps
jeu
c'est une seconde patrie l'unap mais je
peux vous assurer qu'il ya eu un effort
énorme de fait dans notre entreprise qui
a proposé du télétravail et peut-être
qu'il faudrait il songer parce que ce
mercredi qu est difficile pour les mères
de famille où certains pères parce que
parfois c'était des pères qui s'y
étaient mis à cette journée non
travaillée
peut-être que il faudrait leur travail
et mais quand on a reparlé de deux
réformes on vous avait dit que ce serait
bien qu'ils aient un parallèle aussi
fait avec d'autres ministères 1 voir au
niveau des finances du ministère du
travail parce que pour justement donne
une certaine souplesse à certains
parents donc il faut y réfléchir et
peut-être c'est quelque chose qui
commence à bien fonctionner dans le
groupe et qui est de plus en plus
proposé et il faut vraiment y songer
parce que maintenant des ordinateurs
portables tout le monde en a même des
actifs des tâches de secrétariat des
tâches commerciales peuvent se faire à
distance on ne vous dit pas de faire
cinq jours par semaine à la maison mais
si cette journée là au moins le parent
on aurait moins si vous voulez le souci
le souci de les emmener son enfant chez
le médecin etc après c'est une
responsabilité personnelle au niveau
professionnel et un accord avec son
employeur on a confiance on n'a pas
confiance en vous mais il faut réfléchir
à ce télétravail qui pourrait être une
bonne solution
voilà
pardon si vous le permettez puisque
chacun était avec son exemple local je
rebondis sur cette expérience de
télétravail à la communauté urbaine de
bordeaux et mise en place une
expérimentation de télé de travail un
jour par semaine et aujourd'hui il y a
ça fait six mois que ça a été mis en
place et il y a un très gros succès donc
je pense que ce que vous disiez madame
on n'a peut-être pas assez on s'est pas
assez tourné vers les entreprises il ya
sans doute quelque chose à travailler
parce que aujourd'hui je vois que ça
fonctionne très bien voilà danse et art
voilà une collectivité locale qui s'est
lancé là dedans bel exemple donc
concernant concernant les vacances d'été
bien sûr que nous sommes pour six
semaines de congé pour avoir un
allègement un allègement des autres
mais c'est vrai que le tourisme a
fortement réagi quand on avait proposé
ces six semaines l'été et un moment
donné à un moment donné il va bien
falloir trancher vous souvenez quand on
est passé en 2008 à la semaine des
quatre jours le corps enseignant n'était
pas du tout favorable à l'époque parce
que justement diminuer certaines
vacances à et après maintenant quand on
est revenues à quatre jours et demi je
peux vous assurer qu'au démarrage ce
n'est pas pour du tout hein il avait
pris non mais attendez il faut être face
à la réalité moi j'ai eu la chance mes
enfants ont eu la chance d'avoir une
dérogation à l'époque où il était en
élémentaire et maternelle d'avoir la
semaine à 4 jours et de temps en temps
il y avait un samedis travaillés un
samedi matin travaillé et là
effectivement et on a un constat aussi
que quelques quelques écoles ont pris le
mercredi et se rendent compte que c'est
pas forcément la meilleure solution
mais il n'est pas prévu qu'on puisse
revenir la seconde année sur le samedi
alors je voulais savoir s'il pourrait y
avoir cette dérogation si les maires
constaté effectivement
que le mercredi fonctionnent pas si bien
que ça peut-il y avoir une possibilité
de revenir sur le samedi parce que ça
pas dans le décret c'est pas noté 1 donc
vous avez une réponse à nous apporter
sur ce sujet là a pas
d'âme fontaine terminé sa sa réponse
voilà donc sinon concernant le temps de
travail je voulais évoquer dans les
différentes étapes
journée semaine mon moi mon souci tout
de même même si les enfants ont moins de
travail il reste toujours et c'est pour
ça qu'on va reparler de ce télétravail
il reste toujours en dehors de la maison
entre 8 et 10 heures et pour moi ça
changera pas grand chose au rythme bio
biologique de l'enfant la crown aubry
dont on parle tous parce que aller pour
qu'on n'employait pas ces termes là mais
on se basait sur sur le livre qui est la
fatigue à l'école du docteur vermeil en
76 et tout le monde en quelque sorte
c'était la chronobiologie de l'enfant
nous parler on n'en voyait pas ce terme
à l'époque et toutes les évolutions
qu'ont essayé de s'adapter
suivant les différents gouvernements se
sont basés sur ce livre là en 76 et en
fin de compte on pourra toujours des
mêmes sujets sains donc à mon avis tant
qu'on se sera pas mis d'accord avec les
autres ministères l'ensemble du
gouvernement pour essayer d'harmoniser
tout ça parce que toute façon le travail
tous rentrent en ligne de compte on aura
difficilement difficilement les enfants
en dehors de la maison moins de six
heures c'est pas possible
entre six et huit heures je n'y crois
pas donc
voilà je vais laisser juste la parole de
petites minutes à monsieur hardy qui
voulait rebondir sur une des questions
il compte concernant les contradictions
du mercredi du samedi alors j'ai la
chance pour pas d'être base des sur une
commune d'être les plantes est la seule
commune du bassin de saint quentin en
yvelines a passé sur la semaine des
quatre jours et demi voilà et
effectivement on travaille donc depuis
l'année dernière sur avec le comité de
pilotage et de suivi et même
personnellement j'étais favorable au
mercredi matin et je pense qu'on devra
s'appuyer pour la rentrée 2014 sont les
communes qui sont déjà passés en 2013 où
nous constatons déjà nous constatons
donc nous sur notre commune que les
enfants dès le jeudi il commence à être
hors circuit déjà qu'ils sont endormis
en classe et et le vendredi on les
enseignants ait pratiquement plus à
l'est les maintenir en état des
captations donc voilà c'est donc cette
il est important et nous on recommence
demain soir en une grosse réunion de six
ans personne donc on continue de
travailler oui la ville a remis en
circuit la concertation est
visiblement au niveau des dizaines de
toutes les communes qui ne sont pas
qu'ils sont passés en 2013 pour les
nouveaux rythmes scolaires là la
question du mercredi et mais samedi les
plugins et plus dérogatoire
voilà donc ça il s'est par contre il
sera important important de pouvoir
revenir là dessus et concerts et il
était évoqué également le la
pérennisation du du rapport en des
élèves avec les animateurs et des
enseignants et on constate effectivement
qu'il ya une perte d'identité ou de
repères vis-à-vis de l'adulte parce
qu'effectivement on a pas on n'a pas les
mêmes on a les élèves n'ont pas du tout
les mêmes relations entre leurs
enseignants et les animateurs et les
effectivement on a un basculement
négatif dans le respect de l'adulte et
effectivement c'est assez problématique
merci monsieur hardy madame thériault
est ce que vous voulez
est-ce que c'est dans le cas de la
réponse à madame le rapporteur ou est-ce
que je donne la parole à monsieur le
sénateur carle qui souhaitait poser une
question
le fait du samedi matin on parle tous de
la semaine de quatre jours qui pourrait
être une semaine de quatre jours ci on
revoyait le mois l'année enfin si nous
vivions
le temps scolaire différemment gardons
quand même à l'esprit que si les
chronobiologistes sont négatifs par
rapport à la coupure de deux jours du
week-end c'est parce que maintenant avec
le surcroît d'activité proposé le
week-end les déplacements des familles
les enfants arrivent complètement
fatigue et le lundi matin ils ne sont
pas en capacité
d'apprentissage donc une semaine de
quatre jours
pourquoi pas sur le schéma mais vu ce
qui se passe le week-end pour moi enfin
voila je reste persuadé que le samedi
matin travaillé est une bonne chose et
ça empêchera peut-être certaines
familles d'avoir un surcroît d'activité
parce que c'est ça aussi actuellement
c'est que les familles voient leur
intérêt personnel mais
sont aussi en permanence en train de
solliciter les enfants
on sollicite nos enfants on veut leur
faire faire plein de choses voilà il ya
une contradiction là aussi
monsieur hardy vous souhaitiez rebondir
oui juste 50 pour confirmer ce qu'il dit
madame saliou c'est effectivement on
constate depuis le début depuis 2008
effectivement que le lundi matin est
beaucoup plus difficile pour les élèves
qui ont c'est paradoxal effectivement il
a on comprend mieux le surcoût de
surcouf d'activité et revenir au samedi
matin effectivement pour permettra aux
élèves d'être moins fatigués de lundi
matin
merci donc monsieur carle
merci madame la présidente pose une
question très simple du béotien que je
suis et que je pose à tous nos
intervenants c'est qu'on a tous d'accord
1 sur le fait de dire un les rites sur
les plus inadapté il ya consensus 1 que
c'est ce qui compte c'est l'intérêt de
l'enfant d'ailleurs ça me pose des
questions quand on dit c'est ce qui
compte c'est l'intérêt de l'enfant pour
mettre l'intérêt ou l'enfant au centre
du système est ce qu'il y aurait des
intérêts supérieurs à celui de l'enfant
ceci étant dit est ce que les rythmes
biologiques de l'enfant et des
enseignants qui doivent guider c'est
vrai la réforme des rythmes scolaires
est ce qu'ils peuvent être totalement
déconnectée des autres rythmes des
rythmes des familles sains pour prendre
vous commencez par les familles qui sont
pas aussi à une contradiction près 1
entre le parent du vendredi elle pas
rendue lundi
c'est pas toujours la même position
seulement c'est le même par an
bon et c'est vrai en particulier madame
pour le ski parce que les parents les
parents
sont les premiers à dire ce qui compte
c'est les fondamentaux mais il faut
aussi faire du ski faire du ski mais
veulent pas venir au grand bornand et à
la clusaz tous en même temps donc il
faut aussi étalé les vacances et les
professionnels du ski doivent en tenir
compte d'autre part le ski enfin le
skill et le tourisme c'est une partie
importante de notre économie etc si on
veut financer un certain nombre
d'activités faut que l'économie perd se
mettent aussi des finances et donc
rythme des familles rythme des
collectivités
collectivités elles ont aussi leurs
problèmes en terme de personnel en
termes de temps de capacité d'accueil en
termes de transport rythme aussi la
diversité des territoires vous l'avez
dit madame 1 km dans les hautes-alpes en
hiver c'est pas un kilomètre à paris ou
en bretagne et qu'on voit bien là
je veux dire le clash les choses sont
extrêmement complexes et qu'on peut pas
ne tenir compte que des rythmes
biologiques de l'enfant et des
enseignants et est-ce que c'est pas et
c'est ma question plus un problème de
méthode un qu'un problème de fond est
que le décret trop vite la salle limites
à vouloir décréter de m 1 les mêmes
rythmes en france partout au même moment
ça pose un certain nombre de problèmes
comme j'ai parlé du décret il me
semblerait qu'ils aient une proposition
qui pourrait être faite très rapidement
c'est que samedi matin soit plus
dérogatoire mais que soient au même
titre que le mercredi je vais vous dire
pourquoi
lundi j'ai reçu dès maires des stations
de ski entre autres mais pas uniquement
des stations de ski qui disait mais nous
ça nous pose problème parce que le
mercredi matin les jeunes vont au ski
parce que de ce qui pour certains ce
sera demain la réussite au niveau des
compétitions pour d'autres ce sera leur
métier ils sont moniteurs ils seront
pisteurs ils seront perche man ça sera
leur métier est classé vraiment
c'est-à-dire contre-productive donc je
crois qu'effectivement un peut-être que
de faire en sorte qu'il y ait ce choix
parce qu'après tout moi c'est ma
conviction profonde
et au niveau local que ça soit à se
décider entre les différents acteurs
donc est-ce que c'est pas un problème de
méthode plus plutôt qu'un problème je
vais dire
plus politique ouvre mauvais sens du
terme
merci beaucoup monsieur carle madame
gaujac
je voudrais
n'oublions pas que si il ya les projets
éducatifs territoriaux projet éducatif
de territoire qui fectivement est un
moyen
quand on parle projet éducatif
territorial que l'ensemble des
communautés dont j'ai parlé monsieur
sénateurs la communauté des parents la
communauté des enseignants et
communautés de la côte de la commune du
territoire à canton du territoire avec
c'est peu c'est pas simplement la
commune c'est ça s'étend au delà des
limites et ses projets éducatifs
territoriaux doivent permettre la
dérogation est d'ailleurs dans le décret
effectivement il ya un certain nombre de
quatre qui sont posées mais les
documents qui étaient transmis donc que
les conseils d'école ont pu consulter
que les parents ont pu consulter c'était
plusieurs types d'organisations de de la
semaine y avait 4 ou 5 go de mémoire
parce que quatre ou cinq propositions
avec une pause méridienne raccourci avec
les temps d'accueil périscolaire
positionner ou les apc les et les poser
à différents endroits donc je pense que
cette souplesse et je crois enfin c'est
ce qu'on dit à nous avec c'est peu c'est
une formidable opportunité que les
territoires s'empare de de ce problème
de ce problème n'est pas un problème de
la jeunesse de qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
les jeunes pour nos enfants quand on est
jeune c'est 0 18 ans a pour on voit bien
qu'il ya des pommes dans certaines
communes des projets éducatifs locaux
ont sondé justement on sont des
opportunités et les peu d'été doivent
être dans cette continuité là permettre
cette adaptation parce que il ya quand
même des très beaux projets nous on en a
un certain nombre qui nous sont remontés
la fcpe où on voit qu'il ya des choses
ou les élus on discutait avec l'ensemble
de la communauté éducative c'est à dire
les éducateurs qui fait du cuse et du
périscolaire voir qu'est ce qu'on fait
comment on va faire pour que nos jeunes
se sentent bien et grandi dans un
environnement bienveillant parce que
l'intérêt de l'enfant non c'est quand
même quelque chose qui importe en
n'oubliant pas que la france est
signataire de la convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant et
je pense que ça peut aussi s'inscrire
dans toute cette dans toute cette
logique
merci madame marty oui effectivement
comme vous le je l'avais je l' ai dit
tout à l'heure dans le décret
effectivement le samedi matin et est
dérogatoire donc les mairies était
obligé d'argumenter ce qui a été un
frein effectivement à cette réflexion
sur samedi matin il faudrait
effectivement je suis d'accord avec vous
essayé d'assouplir ce texte afin de
laisser toute la communauté éducative
pouvoir s'adapter aux contraintes
territoire on a parlé de l'outre-mer moi
je n'ai pas commencé à parler de
l'outre-mer c'est vrai que l'outre-mer
c'est effectivement un autre vaste
domaine peu sur les aménagements du
temps scolaire bien évidemment je pense
que vous avez parlé de méthode oui c'est
une mise en oeuvre est très très
compliqué et comme c'est très compliqué
il faut du temps et il faut
effectivement de la souplesse pour
pouvoir s'adapter aux moyens de la
commune financier aux moyens humains de
la commune à son projet et puis on vous
disait l'intérêt de l'enfant mais
normalement le projet d'école se
construit au coût enfin au tour des
élèves de l'école c'est à dire quels
sont les besoins spécifiques alors il
est peut être possible et il est
possible que dans une école rurale dans
une école de montagne les enfants n'ont
pas le même besoin en activité sportive
parce que peut-être ils en font beaucoup
par ailleurs par rapport à un enfant qui
vit en région parisienne effectivement
qui va faire peu d'activités sportives
donc effectivement je pense qu'il faut
de la souplesse dans cette application
des rythmes scolaires il faut du temps
parce que convaincre les parents parfois
doux samedi matin il faut discuter avec
les enseignants il faut discuter avec
les collectivités locales il faut
trouver aussi parfois les moyens de
faire ce qu'on a envie donc ça aussi ça
demande du temps donc je pense
qu'effectivement c'est une réforme qui
s'est fait trop vite c'est pour ça que
les gens se crispa sur sur l'aménagement
du temps scolaire et qu'un peu plus de
temps et peu plus de souplesse on
arriverait effectivement à plus de
mme adams a lieu aussi à bram
merci monsieur sénateurs de proposer
cette souplesse vous l'avez compris nous
nous adhérons franchement recettes à
cette proposition
madame le rapporteur
bien sûr le rapporteur nous avons dans
quelque temps j'espère que nous
parlerons aussi des rythmes du
secondaire dans la communauté bordeaux
vous connaissez le lycée du matin et ce
qu'on imagine là aussi qu'il y aura un
schéma national qui supprimera tout ça
alors que ce lycée est exceptionnel
c'est un bon exemple ça trahit travaille
très bien là aussi c'est un exemple de
souplesse de tony faisons confiance aux
communautés éducatives faisons le choix
des communautés éducatives et arrêtons
d'avoir des schémas programmée depuis la
rue grenade non mais je pardon et le
lycée du mirail voilà c'est cette année
c'est un lycée qui apporte une réponse
pour pour un certain nombre d'élèves ccc
c'est par rapport à une problématique de
d'un certain nombre d'élèves qui dansent
se retrouvent danse dans ce
fonctionnement mais je crois que dans le
décret des rythmes il ya tout à fait la
souplesse le la seule chose c'est de
dire qu'il faut écrire un projet bah oui
c'est le minimum on peut pas dire il
faut argumenter voilà c'est tout on peut
pas c'est pas terriblement contraignant
de devoir écrire qu'elle justement quels
projets en voie et à ce projet
correspond à une organisation de la
semaine quoique ça c'est une bonne chose
que nous allons travailler une année la
semaine l'année là actuellement les
communautés éducatives on l'espère avec
les collectivités territoriales
réfléchissent débattent c'est maintenant
qu'il faut leur donner cette liberté il
faut pas réfléchir aujourd'hui sur une
partie des rythmes scolaires et puis
dire on va recommencer demain il faut
remettre les choses à plat en leur
disant nous vous faisons confiance vous
vous connaissez vous connaissez les
jeunes que les parents vous ont confié
ensemble travailler à sa laisse et plus
de souplesse là aussi nous avons dit que
nous étions un des seuls enfin des pales
mauvaise exemple un pays où nous avions
le plus d'heures de cours et le moins de
jours eh bien nous sommes aussi un
mauvais exemple
sur le un pays qui ne veut voir qu'une
seule tête tout est décidé depuis le
ministère ce n'est pas une question de
majorité a toujours été comme ça il faut
apporter de l'autonomie et de la
souplesse pour qu'enfin les gens se
parlent et travail met en place des
projets en fonction des jeunes qui sont
dans les établissements et pas sur un
modèle général
est complétée juste pour répondre au
sénateur carle donc voilà on partage
autonomie souplesse liberté vous avez
évoqué aussi les collectivités toutes
les collectivités je comprends et la
concertation doit aussi passer par là
parce que comme on l'a dit les mairies
par exemple accueille les citoyens de
demain dont qu'ils ont une
responsabilité éducative
justement comme ils ont cette
responsabilité éducative et que l'on met
souvent en avant le problème financier
des communes c'est vrai il faut pas le
nier il faut le travailler
qu'est ce que coûte un enfant qui n'a
pas réussi sa scolarité
qu'est-ce qu'il va coûter adultes en
psychologue médecins hôpitaux
psychiatriques prison assiste enfin
voilà donc assistanat complet donc
arrêtons en france et ça n'est pas que
pour le scolaire de mettre des
pansements sur des jambes de bois c'est
maintenant qu'il faut investir pour que
ces 150 mille jeunes qui sortent du
système scolaire sans formation non pas
n'existe plus mais au moins soit ce
chiffre soit réduit énormément réduit
c'est un engagement énorme de notre pays
madame saliou pardonnez moi mais ça
rappelle de ma part une réflexion très
profonde le jeune qui devient délinquant
ce n'est pas forcément le jeune qui en
rupture au niveau de sa scolarité mais
il ya souvent quand on cherche bien un
manquement au niveau des parents qui
n'ont pas tenu leur rôle d'éducateur et
le premier éducateur de l'enfant restent
le parent voilà je souhaitais quand même
mais il établit recettes cette vérité
mais vous avez complètement raison mais
c'est pareil caisse et nous avons cette
responsabilité en tant qu'association
nous avons la responsabilité en tant
qu'élu qu'est ce que l'on fait pour
accompagner ces familles qui sont
éloignés de l'école qu'ils rencontrent
difficulté d'éducation et j'apprécie la
façon dont vous l'avez exprimez vous
n'avez pas parlé de parents
démissionnaires je ne supporte pas cette
expression les parents ne sont pas
démissionnaires les parents souhaitent
le meilleur pour leurs enfants seulement
ils savent pas s'y prendre donc
accompagner les gens les accompagnons
les jeunes accompagnons les parents et
faisons en sorte
d'arrêter cette roue ce système infernal
qui les conduit vers l'échec mais vous
je partage complètement votre propos ce
qu'elle voulait réagir et ensuite madame
fontaine oui vous savez je joue
oui madame scène oui madame
oui madame saliou vous savez je crois
que les les élus ont bien compris que
l'éducation c'est un investissement
c'est sans doute le meilleur 1 qu'on
puisse donner à ces donc ça ils l'ont
ils l'ont très bien compris et que 6 et
que les si les murs sont importants
c'est ce qui se passe à l'intérieur des
murs qui compte il ya peut-être encore
de la pédagogie à faire le seul problème
mais j'arrêterai là parce que je veux
pas le penser sur un plan politique
s'appelle le lieu de deux c'est
qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas qu'ils ne
veulent pas c'est qu'ils ne peuvent pas
pour bon nombre de communes
financièrement ils ne peuvent pas c'est
clair
suite on évaluera vrai bain et on saura
en fonction des budgets moins le temps
tourne jeu il y a plusieurs réactions
donc je vais je vais prendre ces
réactions immédiatement et ensuite la
parole est à monsieur fauconnier nous
avons madame gaujac madame marty et
madame fontaine
pidement sur le problème du calendrier
annuel se pose aussi derrière la
question de l'organisation des examens
puisque notre calendrier annuel
de ces le baccalauréat qui fait la fin
donc c'est bien une réflexion quand on
vient on a déjà dit on parle de rythme
scolaire ça ce n'est qu'une étape qu'un
des éléments de cette réorganisation
de l'école fin de la refondation de
l'école pardon et c'est vrai que c'est
aussi ce point là qui est vraiment aussi
un point qu'il faudra voir comment ce
baccalauréat qui fait que tout est fait
pour ces tests ce point final merci si
madame kojak madame arty oui pour
revenir sur le décret et puis sur ces
contraintes on a vu que le décret
instaure que la journée ne peut pas
faire plus de 5h30 par jour sauf que
beaucoup d'envié beaucoup d'aménagements
temps scolaire ont dérogé à cette carte
va ce cadre comme la ville de paris et
puis d'autres encore donc il serait
peut-être important de clarifier ce
texte est de dire qu'effectivement on
peut déroger à ce 5h30 et laisser la
possibilité aux communes du moment où on
a nos deux demi-journées nos coûts nous
cinq demi journées pouvoir effectivement
organisé en fonction
de l'heure de leurs attentes en
lamartine nous avions interrogé les
représente au et le dgesco qui nous
avait assuré qu effectivement il est
possible de déroger aux 5h30 d'aller au
delà tout à fait mais comme le texte
effectivement c'est pas très clairs
notre réseau nettement le texte ne
permet pas la dérogation mais les
dérogations étaient possibles pour dire
tout à fait sauf que certains maires il
faudrait donc clarifier les choses
certains maires restent l'ordre dans
dans des discussions dans l'aménagement
du temps scolaire sur ces cinq heures 30
alors qu'ils aimeraient faire autre
chose que la communication soit pas
faite et que clermont disque
effectivement mais les 5h30 ne sont pas
sont juste un conseil peut être une
limite ce seront absolument ce sera une
des propositions je pense de notre
mission madame le rapporteur de
clarifier cette situation de d'informer
les maires tout comme pour la classe de
l'assouplissement du choix entre le
mercredi et le samedi madame fond oui
donc une des questions vous avez répondu
à ma place c'était concernant que le
rôle des parents qu'il fallait pas
l'oublier qu'il était quand même
primordial et que c'était te qui était
quand même au démarrage de l'éducation
de leurs enfants d'accord donc là on est
on est clair et par contre il faut il
faut absolument qu'on conçoit que c'est
sur une certaine souplesse actuellement
parce que si on veut que
si vous voulez si si on veut maintenant
les rythmes on les met en place
maintenant il va d'ailleurs d'autres
transitions parce qu'il va y avoir une
évolution qui va se faire et si on n'a
pas une souplesse maintenant on n'aura
pas une bonne transition par la suite
donc quitte à voir pour les vacances
d'été etc mais
on reste on met un frein on oblige
donne des directives et on doit si si si
fier et rien faire d'autre c'est pas
possible on n'y arrivera pas parce que
ce qui se passe effectivement au niveau
des grandes villes la problématique
n'est pas la même au milieu rural et il
faut vraiment vraiment vraiment être à
l'écouté de tout le monde parce que là
on prend le problème des transports il
est vraiment déjà concret il est il
existait avant cette réforme mais il
faut aussi penser que la problématique
de travail et une demi journée
supplémentaire c'est vraiment une gageur
pour ces petites communautés 1 où ils
doivent essayer de s'entraider entre les
villages etc et j'ai pu le constater
pendant les vacances d'été où j'ai fait
un petit tour en montagne et j'en ai
profité pour aller en voir certains mais
encore une fois c'est bien on on l'a
senti quand même comme quelque chose qui
nous était imposé mais ce que je demande
est ce que demandent les parents
autonome soyez sous parce que l'idée
aussi de travail et de temps en temps un
samedi sur deux pourquoi pas il faut y
réfléchir ou un samedi sur trois il faut
y réfléchir parce que avec ce système ce
système de pouvoir raccourcir à six
semaines qui seraient pas toutes façons
c'est ce qui existe déjà parfois parce
que quand vous voyez les étudiants qui
finissent à mi juillet et qui reprennent
à mi août certains l'ont déjà un ce
système de de vacances raccourcies mais
c'est clair qu'il faudrait une
harmonisation pour les familles ce
serait beaucoup plus facile
si madame fontaine a bien compris que le
maître mot qui revient systématiquement
ses plus de souplesse monsieur
fauconnier
très rapidement de de remarquer une
question bon je m'excuse j'ai pas pu
participer j'avais des auditions sur
notre texte mais bon je participe
ponctuellement à la scission de faire
une première remarque j'ai pas très bien
compris c'est la remarque que vous avez
fait madame sûr je crois que c'est
l'unaf ce qu'il a c'est ça donc sur le
l'interrogation que vous aviez
l'implication des collectivités locales
dans le projet éducatif
nous sommes un moment vous avez dit
alors sais pas si j'ai mal compris est
ce que vous comptez astier l'idée que
les collectivités puissent
s'investir fortement dallas dans le
projet éducatif j'ai pas trop saisit
donc je vous ai une tarification parce
que il ya un vrai débat sur ce sujet
j'ai juste je finis juste pour que vous
puissiez répondre est un vrai débat sur
ce sujet parce que d'une façon générale
les collectivités locales sont perçus
comme des lieux
politicienne une certaine façon puisque
sauf les petites communes où tous assez
mélangé dans les grosses communes
habituellement c'est ça ses clients dans
la tentation c'est très souvent de dire
attention
l'état national serait impartiale et les
collectifs les collectivités locales
c'est à dire les mairies etc seraient
taxés de tous les maux alors yachts et
c'est donc je voudrais que vous
m'indiquer bien si vous comptez si vous
estimez que c'est pas le job des
collectivités locales ou si
effectivement je mal compris la question
voilà vous ai donc pu suivre une
audition sur la réforme des rythmes
scolaires tout de suite la suite de nos
programmes sur public sénat